Õpetaja: Päeva teine video.
Õpetaja: Ee, päeva teine video kohvi ei jõudnudki võtta.
Õpetaja: Mina ruttu, ruttu. Haaran siis. Ee,
Õpetaja: kersti. Kersti ütles, Et, Ee, jah, Mhm,
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: okei.
Õpetaja: Ee, rekordi. Ma panin vist juba. Ei pannud. Vist panin.
Õpetaja: Mm Teeme Screenshare I ka.
Õpetaja: Ee. Lähme meie juurde tagasi selle asukoha juurde. Jõudsime siis nii palju ära teha, et see City Id tuleb kätte, on nii?
Õpetaja: Aa, no mis me tahame teha. On, See et me tahame location form ile
Õpetaja: Ee, tekitada siis ee asju juurde, et hetkel on meil see,
Õpetaja: Mm, ja tema asub siis selles ee Niiöelda esimeses kolumnis. Aga nüüd tuleb siis väljad.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis mõte, oleks et teeks ära. Kõigepealt need kaks välja.
Õpetaja: No mis Mõtted on nende väljadega.
Õpetaja: Inputab input. Küll Aga mis mõtte ta on Veel selle input iga.
Õpetaja: No ka seda võiks teha, aga seda saame alati ekstraktida. On ju, et praegu saame siia ikkagi kirjutada
Õpetaja: Siia Tahaks teha mõned kastid koos leiblitega. Mis mõtted on?
Õpetaja: Mhm,
Õpetaja: Noh, visuaalne element, mul kaks tüüpi juurde
Õpetaja: käsitsi võiks Käsitsi võiks ka teha. Aga miks ta käsitsi, kui on mingi stiiliga? Jah, et ee, vaataks, mis siin on input. I kas leiab ka inputiga leiab ee umbes siuksed, Variandid.
Õpetaja: Kus on label kõrval? Username siin.
Õpetaja: Erinevad variandid, aga pigem Otsime hoopis label.
Õpetaja: Mulle meeldib see variant. See.
Õpetaja: See on nagu päris. Nagu Ta lahendab kaks asja Ära vaata, et, ee suht heal kujul on mingisugune label Väga nagu
Õpetaja: kompaktselt Ja teiseks. Ta jääb siiski alles. Ta Ei, ole lihtsalt lahendus. Olen seda varem ka kasutanud. Ju siis see logimisel
Õpetaja: Võtame siit lihtsalt Selle ühe. Pole mõlemat mõtet võtta.
Õpetaja: Teeme kõigepealt ühe ära.
Õpetaja: Võtame selle siit, ja tuleme Paneme lihtsalt siia kolumnisse. Põmm
Õpetaja: võib praegult olla seal mingi emailadress ja nii edasi
Õpetaja: paneme ta siia. Formil on. Ta siis on ju Kui nüüd visuaalselt vaadata, siis me seda kohe näeme.
Õpetaja: No võibolla mingi üks asi. Mis? Tundub, et on nagu veits, on see, et ee liiga suur kast on
Õpetaja: ja siis seda saakski siin selles ee, eraldi veel proovida. Väiksemaks teha. Ma ei tea. Pane mingi kolm, kolm näiteks.
Õpetaja: Noh, võibolla natukene arvestades, et see see Sisu tuleb siin. Asukoha nimi, Automaatide arv. Et tegelikult see tekst ei Tulegi Arvatavasti mingi monster pikk. Siis ma arvan, et umbes niisugusest asjast on Juba enamvähem abi.
Õpetaja: Sealt on praegu paigast Ära vasakule Mm, savi praegu sellega.
Õpetaja: Praegu on, niimoodi et lihtsalt pildil ei ole pandud Ee, ka suurust. Kui palju pildile on Ruumi
Õpetaja: no pildile võib ka tegelikult juba öelda, et ee maksimum mis me talle jätame, Ma ei tea, Kolm, kaks, vä.
Õpetaja: Nüüd nad nagu liikuvad paika. Vaata, et kell lihtsalt pilt justkui võttis kogu ülejäänud ruumi. Ära. Aga nüüd meil on selline süsteem, et meil on kolm. Meil on kaks,
Õpetaja: kolm, kolm ja kolm, kaks. Noh, maksimum on kaksteist. Kogu see ulatus on ju põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: kuidas saab hästi kiirelt teada, et mis on meil nagu kogu niiöelda võimalus Praegu, kui ma kirjutan sellele esimesele Tv Ile, näiteks korra ajutiselt Style Bloki
Õpetaja: Ütlen ja panen. Ma ei tea, Aqua. Siis ma saan aru, et mis see maksimum on. See on kaksteist, mis on saadaval siin selles kontekstis.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on siis nagu mingisugused suurused sinna pandud.
Õpetaja: Seda style me loomulikult ei tee.
Õpetaja: Okei Emaili, aadress Meid tahame siia kirjutada hoopis
Õpetaja: mida ma ei saa kirjutada. Asukoht Aa suur koht.
Õpetaja: Mäletan seda, et sõna peab siin olema, muidu see label ei toimi. See, et ta Niimoodi liigub ära. Aga võime lihtsalt jätta tühjaks
Õpetaja: see asukoht võibolla suure tähega asukoht.
Õpetaja: Noh, on mingi niisugune farm.
Õpetaja: Jah, Davai.
Õpetaja: Nüüd
Õpetaja: võiks olla niimoodi tõesti et teeme sellest eraldi komponendi. Kuigi ma ütlen, et ma päriselus seda vist ei teeks,
Õpetaja: nagu Come, on nagu, et lihtsalt see Eraldi komponent. Noh, mina ei tea. Kasutad kuskil Kirjuta uuesti,
Õpetaja: et ee. Tekib siin abstraktsiooni jälle nagu juurde, aga sellel on lihtsalt see konks,
Õpetaja: Et, Ee, kui me seda teeme,
Õpetaja: siis me saame harjutada veelgi rohkem. Seda.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: Child I ja Grandchild I teemat nagu et kuidas sealt kaugemale läheb. Nüüd ajab nagu kokkupuude väikseks. Teeme eraldi komponendi Kuidas see käis
Õpetaja: siniseks Tekst pirnikene, refaktor alt Enter ja siit ekstrakti
Õpetaja: taaskis, oli öeldud ka, kuidas see asi võiks ee nimeliselt olla? Võiks olla siis ainult Enter Abstractly Component Location.
Õpetaja: Mis asi oli, Location Name import.
Õpetaja: Jah, Nii,
Õpetaja: ee, nüüd. Väikene mõtteharjutus. Ee, ajutiselt sõbra vaatamise koht. Ma teenkor on. Ma tahan lihtsalt, ee, allergiga natukene teile demoda, et kuidas asjad töötavad.
Õpetaja: Ja siis seda ma ei saa otse niiöelda seal htmilis teha.
Õpetaja: Ta on lihtsalt alert.
Õpetaja: Panen Alert Ee test. Mida iganes
Õpetaja: Niukene meetod on? Ütleme selle vaatamise kohta, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, mina nagu. Panen lihtsalt siia. Alerdi
Õpetaja: mul varem praegu. Lihtsalt tekstina toimus toimus sündmus nii
Õpetaja: nüüd Siiamaani me oleme Event ides. Mis saab Aa saab niiöelda hot, mis on niiöelda sellesse elementide sisse programmeeritud Me oleme vaadanud näiteks ät, Click, I
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen Ät Clickiga praegu, et Alert test käivitaja
Õpetaja: siis praegult on niimoodi, et kui ma klikin siia peale tuleb alert, Okei, seda oleme vaadanud,
Õpetaja: Siis vaatasime niukest asja, nagu mäletate. Ripp menüüs.
Õpetaja: Ee, flip menüüs. Me tegime kuidas see, kuidas toimuks, et see on ju tekstiboks. Vaata, onju.
Õpetaja: Kui vajutan mingeid nuppe asju. Midagi veel ei toimu. Kui Klikin kuskile mujale toimus sündmus.
Õpetaja: Kui tulen tagasi, klikin siia, kõike mujale Ei ole midagi, Kui panen ühe tähe juurde
Õpetaja: Kliki mujale, on Change. Kustutan ära. Unchange mõtled? Saate aru?
Õpetaja: Okei, see oleks üks Trigger, aga Võibolla veel parem. Ee Trigger. Siin oleks
Õpetaja: peast. Enam ei mäletagi. Ausalt öeldes otsin siin. Kas jääb silma?
Õpetaja: Ee Ahah. See vot input sisend.
Õpetaja: Kuidas nüüd sisend töötab? Töötab selline Trigger
Õpetaja: Klikin, Kas tuli? Midagi on a Tähe toimus sündmus B.
Õpetaja: See, Ee, saate aru. Iga Tähemärgi peale reageerib
Õpetaja: Ideaalis võiks olla praegult meil selline lahendus. See on meie kasutaja brauseris ja protsessoris. Mingi väga, palju. Mingisugust ressurssi. Ei, võta selline lahendus, Aga Ta garanteerib siis seda, et ta iga kord, kui kasutaja midagi sa põhimõtteliselt saaks ka hakkama,
Õpetaja: Sest et päeva lõpus. No ma panen Korra Change I peale tagasi see lisa nupp. Midagi hetkel ei tee, vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Aitäh, et kui mina paneksin selle tagasi Change I peale, et mul sellel hetkel tegelikult Kus
Õpetaja: ma. Vajutaks mingit nuppu või? Noh, tegelikult, kui ma kirjutan siia, midagi ei ole muutust ei ole muutust, Tahaks vajutada lisanuppa.
Õpetaja: Toimus, sündmus. Sellepärast, et ma läksin siit ära, onju? Ja teistpidi, et näiteks kui mul on siin Tab Id, ma kirjutan Midagi vaid on Tab, et mine. Teate küll, et Browser Tab I vajutada Niimoodi siis ta liigub nagu aktiivsus. Nagu kasutamata siin ka võimalik liikuda. Vajutan, Tab.
Õpetaja: Ta tahtis kuhugi järgmisse kasti või mingi nupu peale minna. On Ju Näed, ta läks tagasi peale.
Õpetaja: Siin oli ka nagu sündmused, et igal juhul nagu kasutaja, nagu põhimõtteliselt täidab neid väljasid siis ee, viimane hetk, kus ta läheb viimase kasti pealt ära või vajutab Ee, nuppu. Aa, Lisa siis. Tegelikult see on sündmus,
Õpetaja: aga mulle tundub lollikindlam Variant. On see input, et reageerib siis alati iga tähemärgi peale,
Õpetaja: Nüüd,
Õpetaja: mis meie tegelikult siin Ee, tahame. Loomulikult me ei taha seda alert testi praegult, onju? Mis tuleb iga tähemärgi peale,
Õpetaja: vaid mida meil on vaja, et selle selle sündmuse peale hakkaks toimuma.
Õpetaja: Mõeldes, seda et me tegelikult vajame seda informatsiooni lõplikult siia.
Õpetaja: Teeme Missioon,
Õpetaja: Kuidas see on asukohanimi.
Õpetaja: Jah, aga kui me tuleme praegult siia? Ee, tagasi. Mis Mis asi? Siim peab selle input i peale käivituma.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate
Õpetaja: praegu Lihtsalt, Ee, peale input. I lihtsalt tuleb. Allergtest käivitatakse. Aga ma ütlen. Noh, seda pole vaja. Vaata, see on ju
Õpetaja: mis meil peab juhtuma, Nad ei ole isegi ee. Väga niiöelda. Ütleme siis programmiliselt seda kirjeldama. Aga lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate? Nagu Nagu printsiibist, Mis peab juhtuma hakkama
Õpetaja: Eesmärk on. See eesmärk on see, mis iganes on. Kasti sees jõuab otsapidi siia. Jõudis, Mis peaks juhtuma.
Õpetaja: Siin on kõik.
Õpetaja: Otsime mingeid andmeid, et kui siia kasti midagi kirjutan, siis otsime mingeid andmeid.
Õpetaja: Ei, õppe. Eesmärk on teada. Nüüd on lihtsalt ainult küsimus, nagu ka enne, nagu, Kuidas,
Õpetaja: ee, palju, kuhu midagi või.
Õpetaja: Aga miks? Miks me seda? Kas me praegu soovime Näiteks seda, et kui keegi kirjutab siia A tähe, Me liigume kuskile uuele vaatele ja kuskile vahemällu midagi meelde jätta
Õpetaja: ei ole.
Õpetaja: Eesmärk on endiselt see, et mis iganes kasti sisse kirjutatakse, jõuab väärtusena siia.
Õpetaja: Nii.
Õpetaja: Ei, mitte.
Õpetaja: Et. Ee. Meil on mingisugune andmed, mis meil on siin selles vaates No mitte vaates selles komponendis olemas siin inputkastis.
Õpetaja: See peab nüüd jõudma kuidagi siia.
Õpetaja: Ja kuna nemad ei ole, see ei ole üldse see sama fail veel rohkemgi, siin on tegelikult
Õpetaja: Lausa Niukene sõltuvus suhe. Vaata, et meie tahame oma öelda. Et
Õpetaja: kui mina kirjutan siia Mustamäe sisse, siis see Mustamäe jõuab siia
Õpetaja: ja meie Ainukene võimalus seda. Noh, tegelikult. See variant, mis sa ütlesid. Nagu vahemälu. Niuke asi on tegelikult on mõeldav selles mõttes mõeldav, et ee siia tehnoloogiasse on ka külge poogitud Niukene mälu vaheladu mälu, kuhu saaks andmeid niiöelda panna. Ja need andmed saaksid minna sinna nagu ülesse ka
Õpetaja: aga Pigem on siin tä Tegelikult üsna niukene.
Õpetaja: Ee, lihtne nagu asi, et meil on lihtsalt selline komponent, mida on võimalik kasutada, Ee, kus disain Ja kõik muud asjad. Näiteks on juba paigas igatepidi
Õpetaja: ja tema lihtsalt kogu aeg tema. Kuna tema on inputkas. Kui saab teksti sisestada, siis Tema lihtsalt kogu aeg annab enda kasutajale teada, et mis tema sees on, ehk siis see ja mitte on õige vastus,
Õpetaja: mitte muud moodi Ei ole see kuidagi erinev. Kui me tegime selle,
Õpetaja: kus elektris toimub, Change siis käivitub ja mitte Jah,
Õpetaja: ülesse läheb pakikene Noh, siin. Konkreetselt Teisindatakse numbriks.
Õpetaja: Meil on samamoodi.
Õpetaja: Me tahame samamoodi lihtsalt öelda oma pärandile kui sul juhtus midagi
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd on ee, selle vaja mingisugust ee Niiöelda selle sündmuse nime Leppisime kokku, et meil on kõik, mis on meie enda tehtud.
Õpetaja: Nende trendid. Input on ka, Event tegelikult samamoodine vend, Sellist on ema.
Õpetaja: Näete, on. Näete, infot.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ma oleks ise, tõin mingi niukse asja, siis oleks see Event
Õpetaja: infot, Saate aru need on samamoodi Event Id seda tempot.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt meie praegu teeme Custom Event I meie enda venti.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma ei tea, ee, nimeks, ma isegi Ei, mäleta, mis varasemalt oleks. Vali. Oi Type email. Muudame selle kohe ära. Taipe,
Õpetaja: tekst on ju selle Id korjast Koristame ka ära, Seda Ei ole meil vaja.
Õpetaja: Ee, ei kasuta seda. Id D ühel ega teisel viisil.
Õpetaja: Ee, no mina paneksin siis. Ee, mis asi see on? Meil See komponendi on Location Name Inpot Event
Õpetaja: the New Location.
Õpetaja: Main
Õpetaja: infot. See on jälle Potato Potato. Ee, võiks ka mingi muu nimi. Olla vaid Selle üle ma aega ei kuluta.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis me oleme avastanud. See selle kursuse raames on see, et mis kasu on sellest vähemalt müüda selle Intelligence. Ega ta vahepeal on ka targemaks saanud. Selle metsadusbloki võib üldse ära kustutada. Seda pole vaja
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: ja korda aasta Paneks korra maha teamsi, kuid teamsi
Õpetaja: hakkab siin. Ee, tahaks siin ka ära defineerida, et siin komponendis saab üldse tulla Mingi mitt.
Õpetaja: Kuidas see käis. Keegi mäletab siia. Ee, eksport Default. Ja mits voolan
Õpetaja: siin saab Ee, defineerida mitmeid mitmeid
Õpetaja: Ee, string E, Mis on Event Id,
Õpetaja: jah, et Stringide Massiiv Neid võib olla mitu, et on Niuke Event tulevikus. Näiteks tuleb mingi teine event ja nii edasi saate mõttest aru,
Õpetaja: Siia saab neid mitte panna
Õpetaja: nüüd. Põhimõtteliselt. Ee. See komponent Niiöelda ekspordib seda informatsiooni, et siin on mingid sellised emiitid Davai,
Õpetaja: kuhu nüüd võiks minna?
Õpetaja: Lähme Siis üks korrus ülesse poole, et lähme oma parenti juurde. Kustutakse üldse välja seda komponente.
Õpetaja: No see nüüd on siis siin. Eksole
Õpetaja: siin Siis saab öelda, et. Ee. Kuule, ät.
Õpetaja: Kui tuleb Event New Location Name Inpot,
Õpetaja: siis selle peale. Nüüd käivitub mingi tegevus, mis tegevus siin võiks käivitada
Õpetaja: Ka mitte, sest et see on nagu vahekorrus üleval Rida kakskümmend. Üks on ju näide,
Õpetaja: kuidas Citystrop Towni ee niiöelda infot visatakse edasi.
Õpetaja: No ega siin ei olegi midagi muud kui Copy D on lihtsalt see string uuesti heaks. Jooks
Õpetaja: Müütil on sulud
Õpetaja: panna string ja panna. Väärtus isegi pakub seda vist. Aa, siia. Ta vaikimisi pakub Seda, mis on siin selle Mits I all. Näete, Anni
Õpetaja: nüüd edaspidi, meil on mõistlikum teha kohe niimoodi et, me tuleme markeerime. Siia ära ka
Õpetaja: et, ee niukene. Event Hakkab siit edasi minema event. New Location Name Inpot,
Õpetaja: siis siin valikus peaks lausa kaks tükki nüüd, olema, onju?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui tahaks niimoodi programmeerida, siis saaks nii teha
Õpetaja: sellist asja veel viimane kord, kui grupiga tegime, ei olnud nii et on ka siin vahepeal
Õpetaja: ee, asju paremaks teinud. No ikka seda sama Event I ja samamoodi, et nüüd alt tuleb mingisugune pakikene.
Õpetaja: See vaikimisi antakse kaasa. Mis iganes meetodit. Üritame niiöelda käivitada informatsioonina.
Õpetaja: Meie saame seda püüda kinni ja samas edasi visa Visata selle sama Event iga pange tähele, et kui te sind kirjutate, Event,
Õpetaja: et te valiksite seal dollariga variandis, et kui tahate trükkida. Võite dollari trükkida. Ka
Õpetaja: mina tavaliselt seda ei viitsi otsida. Ma isegi ei tea peast. Kus kuradi kohast seda siit saab? Täpselt
Õpetaja: ei Ole tähtis.
Õpetaja: Mhm, Mis mõtted? Nüüd edasi?
Õpetaja: Ajame see veel ülesse, onju?
Õpetaja: Lähme ülesse. Vaatame, et kus kohas siis Location Views kutsutakse välja seda Komponenti Location Form. Template osa on siin all.
Õpetaja: Tuvastasime kohe, kui see Location Form Siin on praegult üks Event,
Õpetaja: mis oli seal New City Selected. Nüüd tuleme siia alla entriga.
Õpetaja: Ät, Mis me siit valime?
Õpetaja: Noh, Event New Location.
Õpetaja: Võrdusmärk Muster on ees. Vaata, mis oli meie plaan
Õpetaja: Plaan. Plaan oli kuidagi Location objekti täiendada, oli nii?
Õpetaja: See on ju siis see objekt, kus mis Me saadame. Lõpuks saadame süsteemist välja
Õpetaja: ma siis siia kirjutaks. Mis ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Tšau,
Õpetaja: jah. Vaadake, kuna see mudel on all olemas. Kui mõinna on nüüd, niimoodi, et ta pakub neid asju sinna sobivad, et läheme. Võtame oma back and täpselt selle objekti, mida on vaja saata. Paneme selle oma mudelisse
Õpetaja: täida. Kõik väljad on põhimõtteliselt Ja pane sõnum teele, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Okei, Davai.
Õpetaja: Ee. Siit. Valime siis selle Location name. I ee. See võiks siis töötada.
Õpetaja: Saame Siis ju vaadata ka.
Õpetaja: Teen selle. Teen ühe Refresh I ka.
Õpetaja: Vaata, Location View D ja seda Location Objekti. Olin uue linna. Kirjutan siia Aa,
Õpetaja: korra Klikin mujale. Tulen, vaatan uuesti.
Õpetaja: On kaks ja Location Name on tühi, on nii?
Õpetaja: Midagi vist on siis valesti Kuskil Vaatame,
Õpetaja: kus ta üldse on? Kas ta siin on
Õpetaja: siin, ma ei saa vaadata. City Structown on esimene.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: mm. Korra teeks Refresh I veel
Õpetaja: ole Nagu kindel selles plikin korra mujale ka.
Õpetaja: Nagu mulle justkui tundus. Et Kõik on ee. Kenasti
Õpetaja: näitab tühjast ringi ehk halb väärtust.
Õpetaja: No, siin on koodis kuskil mingi pugi.
Õpetaja: Aa, noh, ongi. Pugi ei tule uut väärtust.
Õpetaja: Noh, leiabugi, mis on valesti.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: See On valesti?
Õpetaja: Ei, sellepärast, et Location I sees ainult niuke objekt ongi, onju? See saan õigesti, aga
Õpetaja: midagi on nagu ikkagi puudu. Vastus on põhimõtteliselt silme ees,
Õpetaja: Jah, Meie praegu puudume näpuga teda, et ka enda. Nagu lugeda on meil.
Õpetaja: Aga me ei väärtusta teda.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis ta ju ei muutu, Paned Võrdusmärgi
Õpetaja: ja event. Nüüd on nagu see, et alt tuli Pakikene pole hea. Pöördume muutuja poole. Location Punkt location name. Anna talle uus väärtus.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd see Aa võiks just töötada. Aa, vaatame Location You Location ka ei ole,
Õpetaja: Näitab location. Name on under Fine.
Õpetaja: Mm vaatame siis Kas eelmises etapis midagi on valesti?
Õpetaja: Mul ei jää silma Siin ka.
Õpetaja: Location Name Inpot tuleb välja. Läheb uus Event New Location Name input
Õpetaja: Event New Location Name Inpot siin. Ma vaatan ka üle Event New Location Name Inpot peaks justkui andma uue väärtuse,
Õpetaja: aga ei, tööta paneme Veel ühe Refresh I otsa. Veel ühe Refresh I otsa.
Õpetaja: Võibolla vaatan inspekti kapis. Ee, seda varianti,
Õpetaja: kuigi ta peaks töötama enamvähem samamoodi, aga Olen näinud küll ka mingeid anomaaliaid väärtust ei ole.
Õpetaja: Aga mis seal, Event iga kaasa anti? Muidu Event. Iga
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et ma näen ühte asja, mis mind paneb. Ee, paneb mõtlema. Pange tähele, et ta selles mõttes ikkagi muutub. Ta muutub tühjast ringiks. Underfind, Ehk nagu pole väärtust,
Õpetaja: Et, Ee, no teeme korra lihtsalt nagu vaata onju, et kui ma panen siia lihtsalt mingi väärtuse korra, panen lihtsalt. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, looge nagu Sulud. Ee,
Õpetaja: test. Üks, kaks, kolm.
Õpetaja: Et Kas see event. Vaata, alguses on tühistring. Ma nagu üritan. Step by Step. Ma üritan aru saada, Et kas nagu see pakikene ei taha tulla kuidagi kaasa,
Õpetaja: et, ee, kui ma vaatan Location View D, alguses, on ta tühistring ma panen Mingi sisu
Õpetaja: klikin kuskile mujale. Korra klikin siit ka kuskilt mujale.
Õpetaja: See test, üks, kaks, kolm. Nii et Event ülesse tuleb igal juhul olete Nõus, et Event tuleb, aga ei tule väärtust.
Õpetaja: Praegu juba võin.
Õpetaja: Mul on veel päris toimiv lahendus, aga võin selle Push I ära teha, Siis saate
Õpetaja: sa tuled järgi ja siis samal ajal ma, saan ee, pusida.
Õpetaja: Mm, okei,
Õpetaja: no palun. Väga.
Õpetaja: Probleem ongi ju siin.
Õpetaja: Mit ime See on see kõige esimene vaata kast. Kast ise on ju.
Õpetaja: Kui tuleb input, muudatus, emiit ime, kes selle puugi üles leegistas, Ei panegi midagi kaasa.
Õpetaja: Kas te mäletate, kuidas saab kannav kaasa? See on input kastikene.
Õpetaja: Ee, see sisu, mis siin on, on tegelikult atribuudis value,
Õpetaja: Nii siis peale koma saab, panna. Et mis siis pakina kaasa läheb?
Õpetaja: Tegelikult see vihje oligi kogu aeg Underfind. Vaata onju, et nagu ei lähegi midagi kaasa.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma saan nüüd selle inputi välju kätte?
Õpetaja: Ei mäletab.
Õpetaja: No dollari siis, Event.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi ütlen, et ma tahan selle elemendi sihtmärgina Väljuväärtust
Õpetaja: Target näiteks. Checkboxil on. Vaata, väärtus. Vaata, et see on ju
Õpetaja: nii. See on input kast. Temal on Ee, väärtus. Mis siis interaktiivselt muutub, on value alue.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd vast võiks siis töötada.
Õpetaja: Keegi proovib ära ja ütleb, et on. Töötab.
Õpetaja: Ma võin ise ka vaadata. Teen Refresh
Õpetaja: Location I Väärtus on tühistring. Panen siia. Aa korra Klikin siin mujale.
Õpetaja: Vaatan üle.
Õpetaja: Aa, mul tuleb see test. Üks, kaks, kolm, sest Ma olin juba siin nagu aru kaotamas, Et miks sa ei tööta?
Õpetaja: Siia On vaja öelda, et uus väärtus tuleb sealt alt, Event iga Nii,
Õpetaja: no for the love. Iga kord ütlen, et nüüd töötab ja ei tööta, eksole?
Õpetaja: Aa location view location. Aa, Ma ei tea, proovin Korra veel ka. Kas ta reaalajas ka suudab näidata?
Õpetaja: Ei, korra vaja klikkida mujale. Ja siis ta näitab seda.
Õpetaja: On Down. Noh, mis siis Järgmisena
Õpetaja: mis on järgmisena järgmine kalli koht?
Õpetaja: Mhmh number of Thems input.
Õpetaja: Kas teeme natuke niukest laiska programmeerimist ka vahepeal kiiremalt
Õpetaja: Aa Okei, kõigepealt Kus see komponent üldse tekkis? Kuhu me ta panime? Ta on isegi õiges kohas.
Õpetaja: Nii teeme niimoodi. Control, C, Control.
Õpetaja: Aga kusjuures kontroll tee töötaks. Enam pole nagu läinud.
Õpetaja: Ei, siis ta läheb kuhugi.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, mis seal teeb. Mingit muud funktsiooni. Kontroll C, control, V, Ei, Click Control, C, control, V.
Õpetaja: Mis Me selle nimeks paneme?
Õpetaja: Kõik lõpuks.
Õpetaja: Mhmh,
Õpetaja: me peame ainult muutma. Ära on ju, et Ee,
Õpetaja: copy Based Iga ta name i suutnud ära muuta. Mis selle faili nimi on?
Õpetaja: Siin on samamoodi. Nimi on number Offs Input
Õpetaja: nüüd see event, mida Ta võiks hakata. Mittima on event new number off Htms input.
Õpetaja: Siit võib juba siis copida selle asja
Õpetaja: öelda, et see input hakkab siis
Õpetaja: saatma ülesse sellist Event I ta, et ta kattub sellega.
Õpetaja: Ja üks asi mis on, vaja veel ära muuta, on See et taipan tekst, Mis me sellest arvame, Number
Õpetaja: Aa, päeva lõpuks tuleb meeles hoida nüüd seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, missugu Mis tüüpi info läheb? Vaata, mis tahes vormi väljalt, Nagu tüübi mõttes. See on String
Õpetaja: Seda kohta näete. Siin see praegult hakkab ülesse. Kui tekst jätame ta esialgu siia, aga me tuleme tagasi
Õpetaja: Ee, label.
Õpetaja: Automaatide tarbija.
Õpetaja: Automaatide arv. Kõlab nagu väga sõjavärgi moodi, aga hea küll.
Õpetaja: Ee, Jah,
Õpetaja: Mis nüüd? Edasi, Siin on kõik vist vä. Siin vist on. Kõik.
Õpetaja: Võiks siis minna. Koorus kõrgemale. Olete nõus?
Õpetaja: Nüüd otsime koha ülesse, kus kutsutakse välja. Number of
Õpetaja: ei ole veel sellepärast, et me tegime teistmoodi Praegult onju, et me ei teinud niimoodi, et tegime siia koodilõigu ekstrakte. Siis me tegime sellest. Ee, komponendi. Vaid me, Lihtsalt, ee, Copy Based Isime olemasoleva komponendi ja mudisime ta nagu normaalseks.
Õpetaja: No mis me siis teeme? Tuleme siia ühe reaveri alla. Mis ma Kirjutan nüüd siin. Mis võiks olla need neli tähte, mis ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Number Of Input.
Õpetaja: No ai, Kõik on käsitsi tegemine
Õpetaja: Tabiga. Valime selle Tema ei tea, kas White on ja teen tast kahe tabelise asja
Õpetaja: või vajutan. Kaldkriips on ühe tagiga. Me tahame ühe tag iga
Õpetaja: siin. Nüüd saab siis selle ära. Jälle progeda, et ee, panna. Ät
Õpetaja: event new number of Htms. Infot, mis me teeme
Õpetaja: miit Ime lihtsalt selle Sama Staff I, edasi?
Õpetaja: Mis sa oled?
Õpetaja: Paneme jutumärgid, Valime Event I nime. Event new
Õpetaja: Location. Name Input Ahah. Okei, siin üleval ei ole Seda Ja mitte, onju?
Õpetaja: Siit tasub see ka Copida ja öelda, et veel üks siit läheb koma.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: paneme veel. Siia. Mäletan, ütlevad, tahtis Pressida juba niivõrd kaugele, et ta vähemalt minul surus. Selle sinna alla ongi väga normaalne. Niimoodi lugeda.
Õpetaja: Palju parem ja siis, siia. Kus jäi See asi pooleli.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta peaks pakkuma seda ka,
Õpetaja: et kui tuleb alt Event New number of üle üles, edasi,
Õpetaja: Jumala eest, Pakikest ei unustaks. Kui on edasi viskamine, siis Süntaxiga Event saab fakt edasi visata.
Õpetaja: Noh, kes tahab võibolla põrutada? Edasi
Õpetaja: I Love Optimizing tõstis siit need asjad üksteise alla, kuna see joon juba tahtis üle minna.
Õpetaja: Kuigi sellest joonest üle panemine on väga okei ja see järgmine on ka isegi Joonest ülepanemisega on niimoodi ka, et otseselt tegelikult. Ee.
Õpetaja: Kui sa arvad, et koodi on parem lugeda ühel real ja ta läheb natukene sellest, Ee, sellest joonest üle on Jumala okei? Pole mina ühtegi kunagi saanud. Tagasi, kus ma olen näinud üle joone
Õpetaja: aga see on mõistlikkuse piires Vaata, kui see tõesti jääb niimoodi viis kilomeetrit scrollima paremale.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis vist tuleks see ka tagasi. Ma arvan, aga niimoodi paned suvaliselt poolenisti üle vaatad täitsa pikaks, aga sa näed seda väärtust vaata et siin, on ikkagi parem seda koodi lugeda, kui ma ei hakka teda kahe rea peale lööma.
Õpetaja: See on nagu tunde Küsimus Ka natukene.
Õpetaja: Mis edasi?
Õpetaja: Mis Te arvate vist nüüd edasi.
Õpetaja: Me tahame teisendada seda numbriks ka, Või me tahame seda teha, aga me tahame seda siin teha. Aga ma ei taha seda teha. Ma ütlesin, et me tuleme siia tagasi veel.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan, et te nagu veel näeksite ühe korra seda probleemi.
Õpetaja: Vent on vaja ka panna. Kuidas Vent on ka sinna vaja teha?
Õpetaja: Tegime.
Õpetaja: Ee Location view. Tähendab, jaa, tähendab, jah. Okei, nüüd Ma lihtsalt. On nagu siin Sai see läbi, onju Action,
Õpetaja: et et nüüd on Nüüd me läheme sinna parentesse jälle ja
Õpetaja: nüüd on meil vaja siis ära defineerida, et mis juhtub siis, kui siit Location Formist tuleb?
Õpetaja: Event Ja New number.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, see on niimoodi, et Location Forum I voolavad alla andmed
Õpetaja: ja alt tulevad Event Id vastu. Meie kaks tööriista on siin ära näidatud. Tuleme lihtsalt uuele reale. Vajutame ätt.
Õpetaja: Valime siit selle. Kui tuleb Event New Number of Input, siis mis tahame teha?
Õpetaja: Noh, Muster on juba ilusti eesmärgiks. Me tahame teha Tulevad alt andmed Soovime oma kokku koguda.
Õpetaja: Seal ikka kirjutame. Location punkt, mis väljale? Soovime uut väärtust anda.
Õpetaja: Martens number.
Õpetaja: Noh, viga, Mis ennem tegime? Unustasime ära.
Õpetaja: On siis nagu päriselt uue sisu andmine siin ühel Real
Õpetaja: Ment.
Õpetaja: No jah, Polegi midagi erilist siin. Rohkemat kui siis korra kontrollida. Aga siin on teadlik puugi sees. Praegult.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen sellele vaatele, teen korra Refresh I, eksju Automaatide arv on.
Õpetaja: Saab siia tähte kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Ei, saab siia numbreid kirjutada. Saab. Toimivad siin. Ee, need nupukesed toimivad. Kümme. On Number on?
Õpetaja: Kümme. On asukoht mm. Okei, Võibolla, on
Õpetaja: kui, Ma teen nüüd. Saab selle kaudu ka et, vaatan korra et, mis siin location Views Selle location objekti sees toimub.
Õpetaja: Näeme, et Location Name I sees on tekst, sest et see on tekst
Õpetaja: Number of vaatimises on ka tekst, Mitte number selle sama asja pärast, et
Õpetaja: see hetk, kus me korjame mingisuguselt vormilt
Õpetaja: mingit infot ülesse, siis Tegelikult see tüüp, mis sinna on Kirjutatud taga on üli savi. Taustal tuleb ikkagi tekst.
Õpetaja: Ei ole niimoodi, et see, et meil on pandud selle input I tüübiks number ja siia sisestada. Saad nagu numbreid. Lihtsalt kui programmiliselt Me korjame selle väärtuse ülesse, siis ta tuleb tekstile.
Õpetaja: Ee, ei ole.
Õpetaja: Oma kohta saab panna küll. Jah,
Õpetaja: no seda seda on võimalik kõike tehniliselt piirata. Mingi script käib üle ja alert tuleb või korrigeerib, onju? Aga tüübina ei ole Jah,
Õpetaja: tüübina Noh, võibolla see võlu ongi see tüüpe üldse. Nagu tegelikult ei määragi. Vaata siis tema jaoks ongi nagu kui sa paned mingi Muutuja lett a võrdub. Paned Kümme või paned kümme koma üks vaata. Siis. Tema jaoks ta on. Ikkagi number jah
Õpetaja: kuidas. Me, Saame piirata Nii et nende automaatide arv ei läheb inimeseks.
Õpetaja: Pole probleemi, Tuleme siia. Input i kasti.
Õpetaja: Ee, ärme siia ülesse pane. Need tähtsamad asjad on Üleval pool näiteks siia alla.
Õpetaja: Tõesti ei tea, Aga pakub see, et Min value.
Õpetaja: No mis on, Ee, tegelikult öeldud, et miinimum peab olema Vähemalt üks automaat.
Õpetaja: Et Et mis pangaautomaadi asukohast? See, on? Kuhu sa veel pilte ja kõike panna Ja seal ei olegi automaate,
Õpetaja: See on Nagu väga tore. Tere tulemast. Meil on siin nüüd ko. Kõikides linnades on pangaautomaatide asukohad.
Õpetaja: Asukohad on olemas automaatne.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd proovida tulla siia lehele teha. Refresh.
Õpetaja: Seda väike väärtuse, Kui vajutan Hool ülesse on üks.
Õpetaja: Kui üritaksin panna praegult nulli aa trükkida, saab. Kõike, onju, Ee, lihtsalt Selle asjaga ei saa allapoole minna, kui.
Õpetaja: Ja, noh, selles mõttes päriselus. Tegelikult tuleks niukseid asju kaitsta igal pool. Ma mõtlen selles mõttes, et
Õpetaja: Siin süsteemis saad praegu läbi kasutajaliidese panna. Üks taustal läheb post sõna.
Õpetaja: Programmilised ka andmeid sisestada. On ju, et see, kui on nagu niuksed mingid kriteeriumid. Siis tuleks nad igalt poolt ära kaitsta.
Õpetaja: Tee kiire komit. Mul on midagi kiire komit. Ma proovin.
Õpetaja: Ee, hopp, hopp, hopp.
Õpetaja: Nii, Nüüd rohkem ma kahjuks kiiruse osas midagi teha ei saa. Nüüd on juba. Läheb. Mingi reklaam.
Õpetaja: Küsimus siia saaks panna sellise.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, Kas õige sõna validatsiooni või selle peale, et ta ei lase sul postitada?
Õpetaja: Lahkud, et.
Õpetaja: Aga mis ma tegelikult tahtsin siin seda rääkida, on See, et kui me mõtleme nagu andmete kaitset, siis tegelikult sa peaks hakkama võimalikult varajases kohas juba pihta ega andmebaas,
Õpetaja: kui andmebaasis luuakse tabeleid, Neid tehakse Script. Iga on ka mingid tööriistad, et lihtsalt vajutad, et uus Tabel valid nime bla, bla, bla. Aga taustal niikuinii toimetab ühel Või teisel viisil. Sql Ee, et kui me loome tabeleid, siis tegelikult seal juba peaks olema piirang peal,
Õpetaja: et siia, luban numbreid.
Õpetaja: Miinimumnumber on Üks
Õpetaja: siis on niimoodi, et kui nüüd programmiliselt keegi ee arendaja teeb selle vea, et ta seda asja ära ei kaitse.
Õpetaja: Eesmärk on olnud, See, et siin peab olema ikkagi üks või rohkem, siis andmebaas. Niikuinii ei luba sulle sisestada.
Õpetaja: Ee, sinna andmeid Sellisel kujul mis on öeldud, et on mingi piirang kitsendus.
Õpetaja: No ja siis on. Loomulikult peaks olema see kenasti ära kaitstud Noh
Õpetaja: peaks ta siis tegelikult olema eraldi error Meil tegelikult. Ta peaks olema selles vägeris olemas. Vaata,
Õpetaja: et viskab niukest Errorit
Õpetaja: mitte. No Location found või või Ee, või mida iganes vaata ütleb. Vaata, minimum number Atms One või midagi taolist. See peaks niimoodi olema. Ja loomulikult peaks see frontlin is ka olema,
Õpetaja: aga mis mõtet On Nagu saata nagu,
Õpetaja: ee. Mis mõtet on nagu siis ee. Saata nagu sellist sõnumit teele, mida sa juba tead, et süsteem niikuinii ei luba ei võimalda või ei soovi,
Õpetaja: et Niukene kaitse oleks ideaalne.
Õpetaja: Kuidas siis tegelikult tehakse? On see, et, Aa,
Õpetaja: kui idee järgi Backend is Kaitsed selle ära? Siis Kind of is. Sa võibolla ei pea kaitsma, aga sa pead siis olema progema, et see vea teade tuleb, onju, Et, Noh, selles mõttes sa ei pääse.
Õpetaja: Ee, et, ee, et kuidas? Nagu ära kaitsta, on see. Noh, kui aega ja raha on, siis Mina ütleks, et. Noh, igas etapis tasub piirata neid asju niimoodi. Aga siin on üks väike naga ka.
Õpetaja: Vaata, andmebaasis on Scriptiga võimalik väga Lihtsalt muuta seda neid kitsendusi laiemaks. Vähemalt kindlasti. Noh, andmed. Kui sul juba andmed olemas, siis kitsamaks teha, on keerulisem, sest et võibolla andmebaasis On juba mõned read. Vaata, mis ei vasta nendele kitsendustele. Sa pead Scriptiga ära muutma.
Õpetaja: Ee, et sobiks on ju, aga, aga laiendada saab alati tegelikult andmebaasi suht. Lihtsalt, et ma ei tea, annad seal mingid.
Õpetaja: Ee, ühed tingimused. Sa. Sa muudad kuidagi relaxemaks, et ütled, et ma Ei tea, kasutajanimi on ainult kaksteist tähemärki. Vaata nüüd, Ühel hetkel ütleb, ee, saab olla kakskümmend, on ju? No problem,
Õpetaja: Ee, et ee. See Mõte on nagu see. Vaata, et kui me teeme nagu programmiliselt ka neid kitsendusi
Õpetaja: niiöelda, siis tulebki sellega arvestada, mida mitme, mida rohkemates kohtades Need kitsendused. On? Kui nüüd äripool, nagu võtab selle otsuse vastu, et siin nagu soovime midagi kitsendada, siis sul on põhimõtteliselt kolm, kohta, kus Sa pead selle asja korda saama, onju? Võibolla andmebaasis, pakendis ja frontend is, Kui need kitsendused, on seal olemas,
Õpetaja: et noh, mis kasu on Sellest, kui sa andmebaasis lubad. Kahtekümmet tähemärki järsku. Aga sinu ei luba
Õpetaja: või? Mis Kasu on sellest su backendi andmebaas Lubavad? Kahte tä kahtekend. Tähemärki Aga frontend is kus kasutaja saab sisse asju toksida. Sealt ikka ei lubata, et siis on nagu need nagu mõttekohad, et asjad ei Ole tihtipeale nagu nii mustad ja valged tuleb mõelda.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd on see paigas. Aa, selles mõttes on ta paigas, et see kasutajaliides Aa, vähemalt selle noolekasega ei luba. Aga palun väga, pane miinus üks.
Õpetaja: Noh, nothing will stop me
Õpetaja: but the will be as stop kui seda nuppu vajutab, siis on nagu, et. No
Õpetaja: okei, ee, saime sellega hakkama.
Õpetaja: On Ee, another One Done on ju?
Õpetaja: No me saame vaadata palju meil idee praegu on olemas. See on olemas. Need kolm on olemas, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ahah, Davai.
Õpetaja: Ee, Midagi, mida taaskis ei ole,
Õpetaja: sest et Ma lisasin selle juurde. Vaatan, kuidas ajaga jõuab. Kas jõuame natukene demoda kaardi kaardi? Funktsionaalsust? Kuidas saab kaarte näiteks lisada
Õpetaja: kasutamine niukest raamist, nagu Täiesti tasuta.
Õpetaja: Google maps. I lisamine. Vähemalt niiöelda sellisel dünaamilisel Ja tähendab, seda, et appi päringud, mis maksavad
Õpetaja: mingi. Ma ei tea, paari dollari eest saad. Mina ei tea mingi tuhandeid Ee, koole. Vaata, et iseenesest ta kallis ei ole. Aga see maksab, et ma mõtlen seda, et Kui te teeksite mingi oma rakenduse, tahaksite seal mingit funktsionaalsust, kus mingeid erinevaid asukohti saab vaadata või sa saad selectida midagi, saad mingid nimed ja asjad kätte. Kui sa tahad seda läbi Google Maps appi teha,
Õpetaja: siis see on tasuline.
Õpetaja: See ei ole kallis.
Õpetaja: Noh, eriti nagu mingi Eesti mastaabis. Kui sul on kasutajaid vähe vaatad. Sul on mingi kopikad, on ju kui sedagi.
Õpetaja: Aga noh, kui sul on mingisugune niukene platvorm, Kus on mingi miljoneid kasutajaid? Siis võib olla pluss keegi võib teha ka Niimoodi Leiab selle sinu süsteemi.
Õpetaja: Näeb, et sul on seal kaart tahab sulle kahju teha,
Õpetaja: Saada mingi rämedalt Lihtsalt Scripti või robotiga. Lihtsalt päringuid.
Õpetaja: Noh Sentidest saavad dollarid dollaritest saavad kümned dollareid kümnetes dollaritest saavad Sajad ja terve kaua, onju,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, see on ju ka Tegelikult ründe. Vektor on ju, et kui sul see on, noh, saab kõike kaitsta, et sealt midagi jälgida. Et,
Õpetaja: ee, keegi teatud sagedusega midagi pärib, Siis paned mingi bloki peale. Aga see on ka arendus ja vaev Ja seega mingi tehniliselt on kindlasti piisavalt keeruline Asjaga kindlasti tehtav, aga lihtsalt asjad, mida mõelda. Et kui sul on mingi tasuline,
Õpetaja: ee, tasuline Niiöelda asi seal taustal töötab. Ja see on väga tavaline, et igasugused platvormid ja asjad kasutavad mingisuguseid teenuseid,
Õpetaja: mida nad ise ei soovi arendada Ja teha. Vaata, onju? Nullist, et, ee, oledki nõus. Oled ka arvestanud sellega et mul on, mida minu klient maksab mulle ja selle hinna Sees on ka siis minu teatud risk, onju, et tuleb ka kulu mulle, on ju?
Õpetaja: Noh, toome näite, et ega kõik, kes panevad endale Mingi Aa, ai, sinna süsteemi taha. Eriti kui nad ei taha ise neid asju lokaalselt seal toimetada, vaid toetuvadki seal või
Õpetaja: Ee ongi see, et sa võid teha, pakkuda mingit teenust, mis on integreeritud mingisuguse
Õpetaja: ee ai teenusega. Aga see tähendab raudselt sulle token Ite kulu vaata onju Pead olema väga ettevaatlik seda Ai koolitust õppima. Vaata, siis te ee, õpite Ka seda. Vaata, kuidas asju piirata. Noh, kui meie juturobot peaks Justkui nagu siin praegult võimaldama seda, et me
Õpetaja: arutame, mis ee, tooted siin on? Saadaval või või teenused, või mis iganes meie süsteemi kohta, Aga keegi tuleb, et näed, paneb. Vaata, et siin on minu referaat. Nagu tekstina. Otsi vead ülesse.
Õpetaja: Noh, Mine aa by the way me Selles mõttes sel samal koolitusel. Ee, õppisime siis ka seda. Vaata, kuidas me üritasime murda. Vaata sellest, läbi. Vaata On ju, et kui hästi Sa Kaitsed ära, et pronk teeb ainult seda. Ütleme niimoodi, et seal aknas, kus sa saad midagi kirjutada, toimetab ainult nende asjadega, mis talle on ette nähtud
Õpetaja: ja. Ja mitte midagi muud Ja siis hakkasime proovima, kuidas nagu ikkagi sellest kuidagi läbi murda või või kuidas paremat kaitset ehitada. Mida iganes. Aa, üksnes õpilane tegi niimoodi, et ta läks sinna Elisa juturobotile.
Õpetaja: Ee, läks sinna ja üritas siis seal ka nagu panna Nagu juturobotit tegema. Mingeid muid asju. Ee, see vestlus päädis sellega. Vaata, et Ee. Lõpuks tuli kiri, et Tere, sinuga võetakse ühendust
Õpetaja: ja No Ärge öelge, võtsid ühendust. Vaata, ütles kohe. Ja Ei, Ma lihtsalt. Nagu proovisin. Vaata, Ja nagu, ee, Midagi õppisin ja midagi taolist vaata on, ju aga mõtlemas siin oma paketi üle sai soodsama paketi, kui mistahes reklaamiga oli võimalik saada.
Õpetaja: Ee, midagi sai vastu ka. Ta oli nagu Väga häbi selle üle.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ta sai.
Õpetaja: Ee, et selles mõttes on tasuliste teenustega alati see konks
Õpetaja: Google mapsiga, aga mis pikk jutt Lõikud Juttu on nüüd see, vaata et näete seda. Longtitud laditud ilmakaared.
Õpetaja: Meie teeme ka nüüd. Ee, taaski väliselt. Ee, Teeme ühe kasti juurde
Õpetaja: Ja muudame natukene teksti. Ka See asukoht paneme. Muudame label I ära asukohanimi. Lähme otsime selle komponendi ülesse.
Õpetaja: Location Name Inpot. Siin oli asukoht asukoha nimi, Midagi taolist
Õpetaja: Ja siis. Mis me teeme on see, et me võtame selle sama Location Name Input I ja me teeme tast Veel ühe Copy
Õpetaja: Control, C, Control V ja paneme.
Õpetaja: Paneme näiteks Location Map Id. Vot
Õpetaja: nüüd esimeses coopis. Me teemegi praegult niimoodi, et me Saame selle asukoha määrata. Ära lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: ee. Niiöelda teksti kujul. Ee, koordinaatide andmetega.
Õpetaja: Kus me need koordinaadi andmed mugavalt Saame Näiteks Ma palun väga Google maps.
Õpetaja: Ee, panen Maps O. Otsin mingisuguse asukoha. Noh, Bcs koolitus. Näiteks aia Tänav. Saan Mingisuguse punkti kätte. Siin
Õpetaja: Tuled klikid. Ma ei tea, kas te teate või mitte. Klikin siia peale Näete. Seda siin nüüd. Nüüd,
Õpetaja: et panin Bc S koolituse, Leidsin mingi punkti ja teed Parema kliki. Noh, sa võid kuhu iganes teha. Parema kliki. Muidugi. Aga teen lihtsalt parema kliki selle koolituse peale. Siin on koordinaadid,
Õpetaja: Ee, kui seda praegu kuskile. Paste ida, siis ta tuleb teksti kujul. Me teeme niukse kasti mis võtab mingi niukse asja võtab sisse,
Õpetaja: saate seda aru, et see on nagu praegult Niukene salong on niikuinii tabelis. Ee, ka määratud. Ee praegusel etapil.
Õpetaja: Kui toote Tabelit Location siin on, pakkuge mis See n tähendab siin
Õpetaja: ei tähenda, sest, et ee, number tähendab Numeeric kümme. Kuni seitse
Õpetaja: mis. See on palju teistel Asjadel ei ole kuskil Enni, vaata. Ainult. Nad andsid kaks. No kuidas
Õpetaja: vot siin Seda Tehakse, kuidas kunagi. Vaata seda, et. Kas see, tähendab see N tähendab, seda, Et Ta võibolla on all Või ta vist ei või olla, et Kuidas nendel skeemidel ta võib olla erinevad,
Õpetaja: aga selles kontekstis, kus see Skeem on nagu võetud See tähendab
Õpetaja: nolla plaan, et see tähendab, et ta võib tühjaks jääda, et ta ei pea olema.
Õpetaja: Aga võibolla meie Pigem paneme selle suunda, et on. Kuidas? See on nagu väikene kõrvalpõige. Mida need kümme seitse tähendavad pakkuge.
Õpetaja: Jõudnud mm.
Õpetaja: Newtonit. On taga newtonid Mida tähendab kümme ja seitse nummerik
Õpetaja: kas? See Kümneid süsteemi mingi seitse kohta
Õpetaja: peaaegu? Kümneid süsteemi ei ole aga kokku kümme numbrit millest seitse on peale koma.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et maksimum kolm numbrit ees. Seitse numbrit taga oma.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, siin me näeme. Tegelikult on vaatame. Noh, Ee, üks kumb. Ükski nendest saab olla ka sajaga. Ma ei tea, mul kunagi. Ei ole meeles kumb mul ei ole kunagi meeles, ka, Kas on longitud? Laditud või lätitud Longitud, et mis? Mida need numbridivad Ma pakun, et on longitud Laditajad?
Õpetaja: Ma pole kindel, mis järjekorras saame. Selle teada. Ee anyway. Kaks märki. Siin on on
Õpetaja: üks, kaks, kolm, neli, viis, kuus, seitse, kaheksa üheksa, kümme, üksteist siin. See täpsus. On Nagu mingi ajuvaba. Mingi. Ma ei tea millimeetri täpsusega.
Õpetaja: Ee, see juba annab Sentimeetrid kätte. Üks, kaks, kolm, neli, viis, kuus, seitse. Midagi taolist See on juba tegelikult väga täpne.
Õpetaja: Kuidagi nii saate seda küsida. See on Chat I küsimus, et, noh, mitu numbrit tähendab? Millist täpsust Ee asukohal.
Õpetaja: Aa, kuidas see süsteem toimib? On siis see, et ta lihtsalt sööb ülejäänud need ära lihtsalt
Õpetaja: võtta jäävad need, mis on okei, aga see hiljem Teeme siis selle kasti valmis.
Õpetaja: Ee Location Map. Input. Teeme siin ka siis kõik jälle korda. Vaatad selle, Name on Location
Õpetaja: Map Input Event, onju? New Location Map Input
Õpetaja: Event, Mis siit välja läheb? On Location map input.
Õpetaja: Ee, tekst. Ta võib olla.
Õpetaja: Ja, aa, su koha koordinaadid.
Õpetaja: Ma olen veits, düssikohad Ja on see ikka õigesti koordinaadid.
Õpetaja: Kõige tõenäoliselt, et pole.
Õpetaja: No nüüd teeme seda riburada. Pidi seda sama asja.
Õpetaja: Aga veits läheb see lõpplaag teistsuguseks.
Õpetaja: Tuhat Teisel grupp, kellega ma seda niimoodi teen?
Õpetaja: Ma pole nagu seda kaardivärki õpetanud. Ma olen teinud mingi väikse eraldi loengu selle kohta. Aga seekord ma tahaks teha niimoodi, et oleks siis näited niiöelda meie enda andmebaasi pealt juba päris Noh, saab panna, nagu
Õpetaja: on hea Lähme siis Ee korrus kõrgemale.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis Location Form input.
Õpetaja: Ütleme, et peale Number of Input I tulebki, siis see, et küsime Location Name Inpot, Ellen. Nii, Ellen. Nii,
Õpetaja: teil on nii nii.
Õpetaja: Oi, aga vale asi Lmi õppes, onju? Nüüd on siin Midagi hullu on Siin Map Input.
Õpetaja: Paneme siia. Selle saab aru, et tahame üksik tag Ina seda.
Õpetaja: Nii, Temal on samamoodi Event
Õpetaja: New Location Map input.
Õpetaja: Kui see tuleb selle sama asja edasi.
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et sulud ära. Paned selle üleka ära ja valime siit.
Õpetaja: Ahah, ta valib, Seda, mis siin järjekorras on onju? Teeme siit ka. Tublikaadi.
Õpetaja: Ee. Töötame hoopis Copy Based. Parem
Õpetaja: Saame sinna listi. Ühe korra võib siin tublikaadi teha, et lihtsalt siia sisse paste.
Õpetaja: Saime natukene võitu. Saime. Ei pidanud. Toksime seal neid tähemärke Nii palju.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: mis mind promptis oligi see, Vaata, et ma tahtsin siit ja mittida seda Eventi. Ja ta ei pakkunud mulle seda.
Õpetaja: Control tüük. Nüüd peaks pakkuma Location New Event New Location Map Inpot.
Õpetaja: Ja et unustaks ära pakikest.
Õpetaja: Siis paneme koma.
Õpetaja: No, dollariga event. Aga lihtsalt hakake event i kirjutama. Otsige see dollari variant.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: noh, aa, jah. Okei,
Õpetaja: Annan väga kommissi teha.
Õpetaja: Ehitas koma kohta ainult ühe sentimeetri tähtsusega.
Õpetaja: Ahah, No teate, et sa tulid veel päris Mitu numbrit onju Vaata, mis Google Maps elastab.
Õpetaja: Huvitav, kui täpne see on, Kui keegi paneb kaardile. Vaata, et sa ei saa nagu mingi Kui lähedal sa saad selle äpi. Zoom Ida. Vaatad, kuidas ta seda võtab, Onju
Õpetaja: kaevama tulla Ka Vaata, et ei, ei, see on Teil See on täpselt viis mikronit, Nagu valesti arvestatakse. Mingi viga rehkendatakse pärast sisse.
Õpetaja: See Gps. Tavaline Gps seade. Ei Näita tegelikult nii täpselt meelega Muidu lastakse sul korstnast sisse.
Õpetaja: Muidu lihtsalt kasutatakse neid odavaid Ee. Gps seadmeid pannakse kuskile raketile külge
Õpetaja: Ja saab Jah, ee militaarsüsteemid on need Siis on nagu päris täpsed, eksole?
Õpetaja: No oled ikka näinud? Seda Vaata, et Sõidad. Tee peal ja vaatad, et navi peal näitab, nagu, et Paned mingi põllul vees.
Õpetaja: Ammu pole näinud. Niukest asja juures Pärast ikka Oli nagu niisugust asja näha. Navidal,
Õpetaja: Eriti kui olid need ee ikka Nagu Navi seadmed, Tom. Ja ma ei tea, mis see seadus
Õpetaja: ta saab. Aru Jah,
Õpetaja: teeb ju seda ka. Vaata, et et sa kuskilt Oled paralleelteel, vaata. Ja tema nagu endiselt arvab, et. Noh, et see oleks hea. Mis sa just peaks olema tagasipöörde või või vahetad suunda Ja veits aega, nagu kütab edasi vaata. Nagu, segasin vasakul mida. Sa teed siin
Õpetaja: sest? Et ta eeldas seda et, sa lähed kuskile sinna Kus ta plaani paika pani. Aga sina nagu teed. Mingi triki, on ju? Võtab aega ennem, kui ta paneb uue uue teekonna ette
Õpetaja: Viewse Ka Ee, nüüd siin natuke tuleb teistmoodi. Mis nüüd natukene teistmoodi saab olema.
Õpetaja: Mis probleem meil on?
Õpetaja: Meil on üks kast. Vaata, kuhu siis.
Õpetaja: Noh, näiteks siis sellist väärtust. Ma võin lihtsalt moe pärast selle panna. Ega me praegu seda kuhugi lisa niikuinii, onju? Aga nagu ideeliselt, ee, See ju läheks siis siia, on nii?
Õpetaja: Aga see on üks sisend. Aga siin on esiteks numbrid ja neid on kaks sisendit. Okei, noh, pole Probleemi, saame sellest ka jagu.
Õpetaja: Algus on ikka sama, Kõik mis Ma siin. Kirjutan, mis me teeme siin
Õpetaja: Ad Event ja siis otsime ülesse selle New Location Map input.
Õpetaja: Aga vaadake, nüüd on siis selline olukord, kus Ee,
Õpetaja: me enam nüüd siin ühel real, kuidagi väga, lihtsalt Lakooniliselt ja lühidalt seda asja ära ei tee.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on siis vaja see lähenemine, et. Ee. Ärme siis siin. Ee, selle templeid sees seda väärtustamist Tee vaid, teeme seda. Kus kohas?
Õpetaja: No datablokis. Me peame seda niikuinii ära tegema. Aga.
Õpetaja: Ja meil on nüüd vaja nagu teha seda Trikki, mis me tegime kuskil varasemalt. On ju, et ee. Sisse tuleb mingi sisend. Selle peale käivitatakse meetod. See pakk läheb, kaasa tegimegi nimeni, Sest seal oli tegevus See, et võta City Dropdown
Õpetaja: väärtus, Uuendame selle ära ja too ära. Location andmed. Uue City Id Ga. Mäletate, seal Oli Mitu tegevust? Samamoodi ei oleks saanud teha. Ära.
Õpetaja: Lähme teeme. Las ta siis korra siin. Niimoodi tühjalt Ee, ulub.
Õpetaja: Otsime metsad bloki.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, Kus see need metodsid on? Algavad siin. Need kaks tükki on omavahel, et siia alla võiks teha.
Õpetaja: Meetodil on mingisugune nimi vaja, mis kirjeldab Seda, et me hakkame neid väärtustama.
Õpetaja: Mina teeks selle meetodi nimeks niimoodi. Set.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis? Kas siin oli Lng Lat?
Õpetaja: Kurat, on Mitu tükki, Siis ma paneks väljus. Kui oleks lihtsalt ainult olnud üks nendest, siis ma oleks setter nime pannud. Täpselt niimoodi Set ja muutuja nimi Aa Teeme natuke paremini. Ee, ütleme veel täpsemalt. Kui ma ütleks set Long lng Long, siis oleks mul küsimus, et kui ma tuleks korra nagu niimoodi vaatama neid asju,
Õpetaja: mis? Long Glad Values, millest sa räägid?
Õpetaja: Aga see on Location ja Location Long.
Õpetaja: Kui Ma settiksin praegu, T, siis Ma ütleks Data aru, et sa kirjeldaks lihtsalt mulle, et mis see teeb? Onju, et siin nagu peaaegu ütleb seda, aga mitte päris, onju,
Õpetaja: Saad Location Long Lot values.
Õpetaja: See väljus on Niukene So So võiks ka selle täitsa vabalt ära võtta.
Õpetaja: Teeme selle koodikeha.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, nüüd ongi Niimoodi, et ee vaikimisi. Kui see meetod käivitatakse. No lähme paneme selle käivituse ka ära.
Õpetaja: See tegeleme kohe selle osaga edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui läheme siia templetisse. Kui tuleb Event New Location Map Inpot, siis meie ütleme. Set Location Long Lat on nii
Õpetaja: vaikimisi. Läheb kaasa. Event See See Pakikene ise. Läheb kaasa.
Õpetaja: Chat Location Long Glat.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee. Siis, kui me tuleme siia meetodisse. See meetod ei tea oma välisest elust ööd Ega mütsi. Meie mängumaa on hetkel praegult põhimõtteliselt kõik, mis on
Õpetaja: siin eelnevalt olnud. Kui me oleme. Te peate natuke mõtlema edasi, et edaspidi Me oleme kuskil poodireal ja meil on nagu. Et mis nüüd edasi teha,
Õpetaja: siis kogu aeg. Teie mõte peaks olema, et A, mis on Minu mängumaa. Vaata, mis siin koodis enne. Mis objektid? Mis nimed? Mis muutujad? Mis Asjadele ma saan viidata? Mis on ka kuskilt väljastpoolt ligi saadavad. See on see mängumaa Praegu see mure ongi See et mängumaa väga lühikene. Mis probleem on?
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole seda
Õpetaja: sulgude sees, asi, Mis asi on sulgude sees? Parameeter, et see see tehnoloogia töötab niimoodi, et niipea, kui käivitatakse See meetod siin nüüd Event I poolt, siis Kaasa pannakse tegelikult parameetrina. See event.
Õpetaja: Me saaks selle ka ise lahti kirjutada. Kui tahaks, siis me peaks tegema niimoodi Aga me ei tee Niimoodi, loomulikult. Ja keel läks paigast ära. Ma ei näe isegi seda enam vist korraks. Tiirles,
Õpetaja: Vaatan, kas on sulud teha või ei saa,
Õpetaja: Saan, et siia saaks ka teha niimoodi. Vaata, Siis Ta oleks nagu otse välja kirjutatud. Aga ei ole vaja. Me oleme juba nii targad, et me teame, et ta teeb seda niikuinii.
Õpetaja: Aga mis puudutab sellesse meetodisse, siis temale on vaja see võimekust luua noh, siin ma panekski Lng
Õpetaja: plat. Nagu muuta nimeks, et need on koos.
Õpetaja: Korra Võime lihtsalt proovida. Ee, vana hea alertiga. Vaata, et kas nagu tuleb midagi või Ei, tule
Õpetaja: lihtsalt kiirelt ära proovida. Et. Noh, et kas printsiibis töötab ja siis mõtleme edasi.
Õpetaja: Tulen siia Paste in siia koordinaadid tuliallert, kohe Input I peale. Järelikult see voolab ilusti sinna pärandisse, on nii?
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on siis see, et. Oot, oot, aga ma ei saa ju panna tervet seda asja ei Longile ega lätile, vaid. Mul on vaja need eraldada.
Õpetaja: Mis? Teid kahte väärtust eraldab.
Õpetaja: Täpsemalt,
Õpetaja: Ahah, vot on ju Kui mina praegu saaks joonistada niimoodi võrdselt, mis nende kahe vahele jääb, on komajade ühik
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea peas seda Jaovascripti Ee, niiöelda süntaksit,
Õpetaja: Aga proovime lihtsalt. Võibolla keegi teab, kes on ja oskate kirjutanud ka.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd on meil vaja kasutada niukest meetodit nagu split,
Õpetaja: et ee, Eralda mingisugune string. Ma teeme korra ühe uue muutuja korra. Lihtsalt result. Vaata, et me saame kiirelt proovida. Result
Õpetaja: Ee ja panen massiiv, Ah, Kurat, ma ei tea Davai niimoodi result arrive. Sellepärast, et
Õpetaja: kui minul on näiteks siin kümme asja mis, on sama asjaga eraldatud siis, ta teeb niukse Massiivi, kus on mul kümme niukest
Õpetaja: mis, on niimoodi eraldatud ma? Nüüd kindlalt ei tea kuidas. See süntaks on ee, aga, ma Arvan, et äkki
Õpetaja: on, ee, kuidagi niimoodi, et ma läbi selle objekti enda saan kutsuda välja meetodi split. Ja. Ei, ole nii,
Õpetaja: split, aga Ma Ei, tea, kuidas see asi töötab.
Õpetaja: Siis ma panen. Aa, panen alert lihtsalt kiirelt. Ma ei viitsi siin. Midagi Tee pugida.
Õpetaja: Aa, kuule, Ee, split. Kui meetod. Muidugi, ma pean ju eralda ära määrama. Vaata seda, et, ee, Mis on see sama asi, mille järgi me splitime
Õpetaja: Ehk siis siia. Me paneme Stringi eralda need asjad koma ja kõik
Õpetaja: nüüd ta otsib, et kas ma näen nagu niukseid asju siin, kui Jah, siis elada
Õpetaja: sellepärast. Kui lihtsalt komaga eraldad, siis ühele stringile jääb tühik. Sisse Nii, no nüüd peaks
Õpetaja: ühiku. Alati paneb kaasa, et
Õpetaja: me Praegu mängime üldse, et. Ee, selles mõttes, et instrueerime oma admiini, Et kus ta selle saab? Ta saab selle Google mapsist Copy Basediga, et Ta on ja pikk visioon on see. Vaatame, kuidas ajaga on. On see, et võibolla siis teeme, niimoodi. Et kaardilt saab valida selle koha. Noh, Siis, ei ole probleemi, onju?
Õpetaja: Kasutavad kaardid mingisuguse punkti. Kus see pangaautomaadi asukoht on?
Õpetaja: Ja need koordinaadid lähevad siis käiku.
Õpetaja: Süsteem jääb sama, Vaata, ega sealt tuleb ka. Me peame siis võibolla koodi natukene ringi tegema. Vaata, et see kast juhab niikuinii ära, et peab tulema mingi ma Ei, tea, modal. Äkki või midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Võtame sellele.
Õpetaja: Ee, korra Saab siis proovida ka. Ma ei tea, kas seda objekti kohe niimoodi näitab, et kui seda alerti panna.
Õpetaja: Ma panen siia väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Pigem on vist Refresh tegemata. Ma teen refresh I ära. Panen paste.
Õpetaja: Ta Tegelikult Nüüd Juba näitabki ära, et kuidas ma sellest aru saan.
Õpetaja: Tühik on siit vahelt ära läinud.
Õpetaja: Nii kui ma nüüd tahaksin seda kindlalt näha, Kuidas saab Arrae elementide poole pöörduda? Mitu elementi on? Massiivis Praegult,
Õpetaja: Mis on tema indeks?
Õpetaja: Sest et mul ei ole mingit nime. Vaata enam Vaid nüüd, ma pean numbriliselt viitama, et null onju Nullist hakkavad pihta. See viiskümmend üheksa Mis iganes iganes on positsioonil null ja tema on positsioonil. Üks
Õpetaja: massiivide värk. Ja sa ei tea, millest ma jahun. Palun vaadake ära ja videod uuesti. Ma panen siia mitte punkti, vaid panen Nurgalised sulud,
Õpetaja: Massiivi element Null No nüüd peaks tulema ainult üks nendest. Siia tuli.
Õpetaja: Tuli see mingi viiskümmend üheksa, bla, bla, bla, kui ma Proovin, et pane siia. Ee Indeksil Element üks.
Õpetaja: Panen based. Tuleb see tagumine.
Õpetaja: Kui panen näiteks selline. Kolm või kaks, siis peaks tulema underfine Või null. Ma Isegi ei tea, mis seal tuleb. Underfine.
Õpetaja: Ta splitib selle massiivi. Kaheks on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kus me teame, et täpselt, niimoodi Ee, me saamegi kätte need asjad. Noh, nüüd on lapsemäng ju panna. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Ma korra kirjutan korra. New Chat. Ma annan
Õpetaja: Google Maps, Kas mul on see paste veel sees? Siin on, ee, Google Maps.
Õpetaja: Ling lat.
Õpetaja: Kumb on kumb
Õpetaja: Ahah, laditud on alati enne Okei. Nüüd Teame on ju, et siis me teame, et see esimene number seal Massiivis on laditud.
Õpetaja: Väga tore Paneme siis selle latitudi paika, mis ma Kirjutan
Õpetaja: Algust. Ikka Teate ju?
Õpetaja: No kui ma tahan.
Õpetaja: Sest Noh, juba tuleb midagi. Vähemalt disse tabasite ära. Dis Punkt location edasi.
Õpetaja: Jah, punkt
Õpetaja: latitudi Teeme enne nii. See on praegu. Puudutame. Tahame lugeda andmeid või tahame anda uusi andmeid. Kumba tahame
Õpetaja: uusi andmeid panna. Kuidas Teeme?
Õpetaja: Võrdusmärk annab uue väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Nüüd just saime aru. Vaata, et mõlemad asjad on sellises massiivis. Aa, indeksil Null on esimene indeksil. Üks on teine, siis, Mis ma siin kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Ma kirjutan ümberrühm üheksa.
Õpetaja: Ei, ei, mitte üks sest indeksid algavad alati nulliga. Teine oli üks,
Õpetaja: esi, sest me küsisime, Kumb on? Kumb Ta ütles? Esimene number. Mina proovime paika saada. Jah, noh, põhimõtteliselt Nüüd saab selle
Õpetaja: publitseerida Lng ja üks.
Õpetaja: No saame siis proovida, Kuidas saame proovida. No ikka vana. Hea.
Õpetaja: Vaatame andmeid ja teen korra refresh. I ka üheks ja üks. Paneme asukoha koordinaadid.
Õpetaja: Tulen vaatan. Location View Vaatan Location objekti.
Õpetaja: Okei, Peaaegu, aga midagi on ikka natukene.
Õpetaja: Selles mõttes. Tulemused saime õiged väärtused On
Õpetaja: aga peabki olema viiskümmend üheksa. Noh, teeme siis elu lihtsamaks. Vaata, et on kogu aeg parem aru saada
Õpetaja: See, kuidas by the way see On hea koht nüüd. Me Vahetasime asukoha omavahel ära Praegu, Kui läheb sõnum läheb süsteemile, siis järjekord on ülikama, sest et on võti väärtussüsteem
Õpetaja: ülisavi. Ma võin saata kõik nad täiesti pahupidi järjekorras. Päike end võtab vastu. Ta vaatab ükshaaval, et mis mul sisse. Tuli Kas ma saan, neid Ee, selleks objekti välja teeks teha. Bla, blabla. Ta taustal toimetab,
Õpetaja: et pole probleemi. Järjekordne savi, aga endal võibolla on Praegu parem, vaadata, kuidas ma seda tegin, Tegin Selleks roheliseks Nool üles, noole alla.
Õpetaja: Noh, võin ka siia panna, aga seda pole mõistlik paneme. Sellisesse järjekorda nagu, nad tulevad sest, niimoodi on Endal lihtsam mõelda on ju
Õpetaja: ongi. Lähed?
Õpetaja: Noh, on pai. Nad selles mõttes. Nad on paigas,
Õpetaja: aga ma ütlen, et midagi on, ee, halvasti
Õpetaja: Pikkust vä?
Õpetaja: Ei, ütlen, et vihje on ekraanil.
Õpetaja: No ma. Pean splitima siis seda. Tegelikult. Ee, või noh, korra peame vaatama seda
Õpetaja: Ja Vaadake, City null number. Fatms üks. Mis need on, punased?
Õpetaja: Kui hakate Editiga vaatama tegemist on tekst.
Õpetaja: Okei, Tundub, et we are not quite,
Õpetaja: Kuidas Saame teha teksti järsku numbriks. Noh, eeldus, et see numbriline väärtus on. Oleme juba. Seda teinud ju. Konvertida Kuidas
Õpetaja: Jaa, konstruktor?
Õpetaja: Me kutsume välja Klassi korra. Võtame selle sisu Control iksiga. Ära. Ütleme number
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd. See konstruktori. Sisse. Paneme eni väärtuse,
Õpetaja: palun Väga Tee see numbriks. Ma saaks kirjutada ka nii ka, et hakkad kirjutama siia ette. Vaata, mingi number.
Õpetaja: Sulud algavad ja tulete siia lõppu. Vaata, sul on lõpud. Vaata, vale. Mulle meeldib niisugused olukord. Saad katega ära võtta, kirjutada. Ja palju lihtsam
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd vaadata seda sama asja uuesti.
Õpetaja: Ee, Nüüd Mul läks mälust ära see juba.
Õpetaja: Võtame siis selle Pcs I aadressi. Varsti te teate juba peast. Vaata seda koordinaate
Õpetaja: Ee. Noh, nii vist ikka päris Ei lähe veel.
Õpetaja: Tulen, vaatan seda. Location It on Numbrilised väärtused sobib
Õpetaja: Ee Davai taaskiväline arendus. Aga kunagi hiljem siis seda kasutame. See ei ole. Mandatori on seal. Ütleme, kui taaskis oleks see kirjeldatud,
Õpetaja: Leian aega kunagi. Proovin korda teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, võibolla niuke koht jälle. Ee, et Saime nagu midagi tehtud Päriselus Siis paneks Ee, mingid sõnad ka sinna juurde, et tegime mingi sellise funktsionaalsuse
Õpetaja: Sööme ära Ei, või?
Õpetaja: Väike võit. Alati võib selle sama enne kolm rääkimist, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: siis me tegime seda, et me põrutlesime.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me võrdle, et siin nüüd, ee,
Õpetaja: see on sellepärast, et, ee, meie süsteem
Õpetaja: on ee. Arendatud, et sealt poolt. Kui võetakse see väärtus vastu, siis ta on ee, numbriline väärtus.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et. Vaata, Meil on Concert. Meil on siin ee, nõue
Õpetaja: teenuse poolt, et sina annad andmed täpselt niimoodi, mina panen korra, onju Ja tema jaoks on see probleem. No vaata, mis juhtub, onju? Ma nüüd ei tea, kuidas töötab sellepärast, et ma saadan korra niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: et Lisa, uus asi. Ta vastas meile kakssada. Vaata, et kõik on hästi,
Õpetaja: Aga mis juhtub, siis? Ma ei tea, kui ma ütlen, ma Tean, kuidas päris süsteem vastaks. Vaata, mis siis, kui ma panen need stringina
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et eeldab, et sa saadad numbrid, aga ma saadan järsku teksti Kui on Execute
Õpetaja: your requesties. Not valid Htt bali validation repose found inspect,
Õpetaja: bla bla, bla, bla. Bla. Vaatame korra, kas ta üritab midagi öelda ka Nagu täpsemalt.
Õpetaja: Request Body Property lng must be a number
Õpetaja: Ta nagu esi, ta leidis nagu esimese asja, millega tal on
Õpetaja: sellega, et kui ma võtan näiteks selle ära siit
Õpetaja: jätan selle lng sinna. Vaata selle lati. Vaata, siis ta hakkab latist rääkima.
Õpetaja: Kus ta sellest räägib. Siin, Oota, siin all kuskil näed, Body?
Õpetaja: Jah, aga ma nüüd üt. Noh, selle teeme nüüd korda. Vaata, onju ja korras. Korras, korras. Panen sõnumi teele. Nüüd ta juba räägib latist. Vaata, on ju, et mulle ei meeldi see asi sellepärast, et see on Contra,
Õpetaja: mina Üt see skeema ütleb ette. Vaata, nagu
Õpetaja: ta ei tule jaoskriptis. Ta tuleb Jasonis. Jah, sest et Jason. Jason nagu annab tüübid ette, Vaata, Siin ei ole seda tüüpi. Vaata, et vaata sealt Jaavas. Võib Nüüd olla. Vaata see, et ta ei ole vaid, et ta on koma kohaga.
Õpetaja: Aga mis puudutab nagu seda Jasonit, siis on meil nagu neid tüüpe vähem. Mäletate Jasoni video
Õpetaja: Aa materjalidest, kus ta rääkis, et sul, Noh, neid tüüpe ei ole väga palju. String number. Polion Object
Õpetaja: nal. Ma ei tea, kas nal oli tüübine või mitte.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, aare video uuesti üle.
Õpetaja: Ee, Vabandust, Jasoni video, et selles mõttes. Ja see peab olema täpselt õige. Jah, kui me kui me lõpuks programmeeriksime nii kaugele Ja kui see sõnum on, niimoodi, siis server saadab samamoodi. Mitte nagu niukse sisuga. Aga mingi bad request või midagi taolist tuleb sealt
Õpetaja: serveri enda poolt. Võibolla tuleb üldse viissada. Ma isegi ei kujuta ette, kukub pikali, kui sinnamaani jõuame. Me võime korra proovida. Mis saab
Õpetaja: Siin ikka. Vist veel läheb aega Ennem kui sa oma serverit saame arendada.
Õpetaja: Ee, arvestame nüüd selle viimase. Kas me eile tegime ka? Umbes samal ajal Tegime vist pausi vä,
Õpetaja: et meil jääks See viimane sutsakas niukene. Mitte liiga pikk, Mitte Liiga lühikene. Kindlasti kuusteist kümme
Õpetaja: kergitame. Kaabut üksteisele ja Lehvitame Aiamaja valmis ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ma võin öelda. Ma pole viimased kolm päeva aiamajas mitte midagi ei olnud teha ma olen lihtsalt niivõrd väsinud
Õpetaja: Teie õpetamisest sul on vaja teha.
Õpetaja: Ja millised on oskused? Ee, plekkatusega. Paigaldusel kõik käed püsti. Tulge külla.
Õpetaja: No näed, seda Kaardi tuleb olemas No jah,
Õpetaja: ei. Te vaatate need videod ära ja ja siis magate.
Õpetaja: Jah, pange. Pange endale need. Ee, pange une peale. Vaata, need ee, podcastid käima Äkki Hommikul ärkad ülesse ja põmm. Meetod.
Õpetaja: Ta koosneb nendest osadest sama häälega.
Õpetaja: Ee, siia.
Õpetaja: Saime selle tehtud. Kas teeme siis hästi? Aga teeme Kümme minutit pausi teeme Lühikese pausi sest, te lähete varem koju niikuinii
Õpetaja: et, iga päev võib viiskümmend minutit varem koju kui, paberid ette näitavad. Aga lõuna on teil viisteist minutit Lühem
Õpetaja: Saate natukene Varem. Ka ju Saan ise ka.
Õpetaja: Päevad on pikad ja väsitavad. Teeme siis pausi. Ma panen. Siis Ee, sellele Break ile ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, pausile Pause recording.
Õpetaja: Ee, share.
Õpetaja: Nii, Jõudsime just ära teha selle selle kasti, onju
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleks vaadata, et mis on siis järgmine asi?
Õpetaja: Ahah, järgmine asi peaks olema siis transaction types. Checkbox
Õpetaja: Mida võiks siin juba aimata, vaata Enne kui üldse hakkame siin sisuliselt midagi vaatama. Just selle osaga
Õpetaja: Sularaha sisse. Sularaha välja maksad.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: need on need andmed need ei tule, Need ei ole Fronti sisse programmeeritud. Nad tulevad kuskilt.
Õpetaja: Seda võiks teada. Siin räägitakse ka.
Õpetaja: Loovus Komponent, Transaction Type Checkbox andmed saadakse Fbi ja Atm Transaction Types teenusega tuleb lihtsalt Niukene Staff sisse. Väike väärtused. No seda ei pea meie teadma. Ee, aga mis on see, et nad on seotud
Õpetaja: nende andmetega.
Õpetaja: Okei, kui te vaatate seda osa,
Õpetaja: siis mis mõtted võiksid olla?
Õpetaja: Ahah, siin ei ole seda niimoodi välja toodud. Aa, Ei, onju terve kaup. Mis mõtted võiksid olla seoses sellega?
Õpetaja: Kangesti korduv?
Õpetaja: See on kangesti korduv. Vaata, et kui öeldakse, et on vaja tuua andmed ära ja teenus tagastab täpselt neid andmeid.
Õpetaja: Siis vist oleks väga mõistlik et, kui me pärime andmeid ja andmete pealt peab, esiteks kuvama neid checkbox, E,
Õpetaja: et kuskil neid peab hoidma. Meil ei ole mõtet teha eraldi objekti, vaid selle sama objekti sees.
Õpetaja: Selle lihtsalt peame ära sisustama, et siin on see mudel.
Õpetaja: Kuskilt peab tulema need andmed, mille pealt Checkbox e kuvatakse, et selle külge võiks panna.
Õpetaja: Okei, davai, no Alustakski sellest. Võibolla, et saaksid need andmed kätte.
Õpetaja: Kui me alustame mistahes arendust. Aa, nüüd hakkame tegema et mingi andmete äratoomine,
Õpetaja: siis ee, mi, Mille võiks lahti võtta? Millest võiks juhinduda Millest, mitte võiks vaid peaks väge. Meie Contract.
Õpetaja: Hetkel on meil siis see Stoplight I näide panen Siin korra. Cancell. Cancell. Panen kinni.
Õpetaja: Paneme selle ka kinni.
Õpetaja: Gat Transaction Type. Siin all tagastab kõikvõimalikud pangaautomaadi. Teenused,
Õpetaja: tagastab süsteemis defineeritud pangaautomaadi teenused Näiteks raha, sisseraha, väljamaksed.
Õpetaja: See on mingi näidis ka.
Õpetaja: Nii super.
Õpetaja: Kust alustame?
Õpetaja: Progemise mõttes. Mis me nüüd siis ee, võiks teha?
Õpetaja: Mina olen Uus arendaja. Väidake mind, Services. Jah,
Õpetaja: Services. Hetkel on meil siin teenuste osas Ee, siuksed servisid. Ee Mis mõtted on selle Transaction Type Service iga.
Õpetaja: Kas ta võis City Sorry s alla sobida.
Õpetaja: Kahtlane Login Service I kohta. Kahtlane Location Service
Õpetaja: ma Võiks võibolla mõelda, et aga see on kuidagi osa Location Services,
Õpetaja: et kui me hakkame mõtlema seda, et meil oleks No Url tegelikult juba Kandja defineerib meile ära, et tegemist on täi täiesti teise elukaga.
Õpetaja: Aga kujutage ette, et kui meil oleksid teenused. Okei, võta kõik. Transaction Type Id. See on üks meetod
Õpetaja: lisa Üks uus transaction Type läbi huvi.
Õpetaja: Ee, see oleks üks teenus. Kustuta, Muuda neli Teenust juba. Anna üks üksikobjektina. Üks listina Potentsiaalselt viis teenust.
Õpetaja: Saaks teha Transaction Type, et iga kord kui me mõtleme, et võiks toppida mingisugused asjad mingisuguse asja. Alla, Vaata, et, noh, nad on kuidagi seotud, siis tuleb mõelda seda, et me siukse lähenemise võtame. Siis kuskil mingisugused failid. Võibolla Ühel hetkel hakkavad paisuma,
Õpetaja: et nad tegelikult ikkagi ei Ole nagu päris üks ja see sama. Ja kui kaugele me sellega läheme, on, ju
Õpetaja: et pigem on ikka nagu. See, et me oleme Arendajad. Meile meeldib asju hoida eraldi. Meil meeldib asju grupeerida.
Õpetaja: Ee, oma omamoodi kuidagi alamkategooriatesse panna ja nagu niukest tegevust. Teha
Õpetaja: Okei, no väga hea.
Õpetaja: Saime selle paika, et noh, siis oleks vaja mõelda, et nagu mis service ta võiks olla?
Õpetaja: Transaction. Lihtsalt ma ei paneks transaction Ee üldse. Transaction on õudsalt halb sõna
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et tehnoloogiliselt neid asju me näeme erinevates tehnoloogiates niiöelda klasside ja asjadena kahjuks. No see on nüüd Ma nagu kogemusest räägin. Et on nagu natukene. Halb sõna. Tahaks veel rohkem tegelikult panna. Teenused Service.
Õpetaja: Kuule, meil on juba Brad siin juba Klassi nimel. See Service Ee, ei tahaks, et kui Entity on teenus, siis nagu hakkaks mõtlema midagi muud välja mingi produkt või midagi, ma Ei tea, mida iganes kuidagi niimoodi üritaks. New Yor
Õpetaja: Reaction Taipe Service.
Õpetaja: Noh, esimene asi, mis me siin failis teeme, miks see vajalik on,
Õpetaja: et pikk näeks, et kõik näeksid.
Õpetaja: Ja noh, kui mõelda selle sõnale eksporti, et siis seda, mis iganes koodi siin on seda võimalik mujal importida ja kasutada
Õpetaja: enda. Nii võib ka mõelda.
Õpetaja: Meetod vajab mingisugust nime,
Õpetaja: mis me siia hakkame kirjutama. Oleme kokku leppinud, et me on üsna Niukene tehniline lähenemine, mis tegelikult tuleb ka selle piibli pealt.
Õpetaja: Jah, Aa, mitte päris peaaegu alguse. Leege aga lõpp oli puudu Öeldakse.
Õpetaja: Oi, mhm, Ütle kõva. Ei Oleks reklast,
Õpetaja: et ee. Ta annab nagu väga hästi märku, et tegemist on juba päringuga.
Õpetaja: See ei ole lihtsalt mingi äriloogiline kood, kus mingi kood toimetab ja teeb midagi ise. Leiutab kokku, vaid et ei. See on nagu sõnum,
Õpetaja: et ära ei unustaks. Ee, niikuinii, Ee, peame returnima selle asja. Miks peame returnima siit midagi? Sest et see info, mis niiöelda siin siis sellel kohal tekib? Ta elab ja sureb nende loogiliste sulgude, vahel
Õpetaja: kes meid aitab siin olukorras selle sõnumiga saatmisel seoses.
Õpetaja: Mis asi see aktsias on?
Õpetaja: No ütleme, ma ütlen siis vastuse ette. Te võiksite mingi oma sõnadega kirjeldada, et on Library jällegi valmis tehtud. Niiöelda kood ja lahendus, mis on ehitatud Fetch api, peale Mis on omaette siis? Põhimõtteliselt programm, mida Browserites on juba kõigil olemas.
Õpetaja: Ei Pea eraldi impordimaksu Siis imporditakse ühe korra sisse.
Õpetaja: Noh, aktsiaselt käivitame meetodit. Ee, tal on siin need kõik need restmeetodid, mis meid huvitab, et
Õpetaja: kui me nüüd vaatame, et et siin on see url parameetreid Ei ole
Õpetaja: ee, post ega ei ole request Body tal olla ei saa siis siin. Meil on variandid. Url, konfig.
Õpetaja: Meil läheb ainult vaja Vabandust, Urli.
Õpetaja: Millal konfigi oleks vaja? Millal oli vaja midagi Konfida,
Õpetaja: kuidas?
Õpetaja: Jah, oli ainult Stoplight I jaoks. Aga kui Stoplight välja ei jätta, Et teda manipuleerida, siis oli palju praktilisemalt
Õpetaja: kohti, kus oli vaja parameetreid. Mäletate? City Id
Õpetaja: saab kaasa Null Üks, kaks, kolm, neli, mis iganes, Aga meil praegu piisab. Stringist peaks saama siit Copy da
Õpetaja: Kui sa saab selle ka välja kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Noh, see juba veits. Niuke, tüütum asi, mida välja kirjutada, Aga põhimõtteliselt on ka siis tehtav.
Õpetaja: Mis puudutab seda koodi, siis. Ee.
Õpetaja: Selles osas on nüüd kõik. Siin saan, aru
Õpetaja: kas Te nagu vaikselt näete, Nagu seda väärtust. Vaata, et tõesti, et meil on nagu selline konkreetne ee, niiöelda süsteem, kus Kõik sõnumi saatmised on eraldatavad,
Õpetaja: et kui mõnus on nagu kohe. Saada kiiret ülevaade, et mis teenused on meil siin tegelikult juba ära realiseeritud Midagi, mida on kasutatav Tuled kuskil City Service, siis sa vaatad, et. Ahaa, siin on Mingi niukene. Värk on ju? Kus on seda kasutatud Klikk, Klikk, Klikk
Õpetaja: ütleb, et paneb, annab kahes. Kohas on ju onju real. Viiskümmend üks. Ee Location views. Ee, real. Kolmkümmend Seitse on kasutatud,
Õpetaja: aga põhiline. On See ka, et kui vurdid peaksid kunagi muutuma Change It ones kasutusel Everywhere.
Õpetaja: Nii, okei, ee. Meil siis oli Transaction Type Service, tema on omadega ühel pool
Õpetaja: kinni panna. Aga me teame, et Transaction Type Services meil see asi on.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, millal on vaja neid andmeid ee laadida,
Õpetaja: millal on vaja saada põhimõtteliselt ette kõik Transaction Type Id, mis on meil süsteemi poolt võimaldatud.
Õpetaja: Ei, no kui leht üldse avatud onju, Siis, ee, mõte. On jälle selge, et before. Kui tuuakse ära ritmenüüandmed, siis samamoodi tuuakse ära Ee, nende checkboxide andmed, onju, et mida on Võimalik, et oleks midagi käivitades. On vaja vastavanimelist meetodit.
Õpetaja: Siis ühtlasi, mis on veel Vaja Ärme nüüd siit Ära veel lähe
Õpetaja: Teeme natukene niimoodi Praegu sammsammalt vastab tõele. Varem või hiljem on vaja kuhugi need andmed panna.
Õpetaja: Kuhu need andmed saab panna? Üldse Nii et igal pool mujal oleks võimalik. Kuvada
Õpetaja: databloki on ju, et siis äkki teeks kohe ära selle mudeliosa. Vaata, et meil on siis kuhugi. Panna Oleme Praegu siin Samas
Õpetaja: vahest oli siin ka kopinupp. Vaata, võibolla päris vägeris on. Ma ei tea, rääkida, Tuleb ajal ei tule.
Õpetaja: Ei, toh, äkki tuleb vastuseks, Äkki, et ma vaatan ka ära? Ahah, päris vastust on võimalik Copida
Õpetaja: nupuga, Aga noh, see tegelikult ei ole ka midagi. Ee, erilist siit kopi taga ära. Võtame selle Staffi koos sulgede ja karvadega.
Õpetaja: Ettevaatlikult, et ei tule. Mingi reavahetus ja mingeid muid. No, reavahetus ei oleks katastroof Aga mingid mingid osalised tekstid. Natuke peab olema ettevaatlik.
Õpetaja: Läheme siis data bloki. Vaatame, kus viimane asi lõppeb.
Õpetaja: Prooviks siis hoida nagu niukest, asja et nad on need kõik omavahel natuke eraldatud. Vähemalt ühe Reaga on ju? Kus see asi lõppeb?
Õpetaja: Kõige lihtsam on tulla siit niimoodi joone, järgi. Nüüd on vaja mingit nime.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, loll. Miks uut muutujat Ja rääkisime oma tehnilist lahendust, kus meil on mõistlik need andmed toppida
Õpetaja: Location talle Vä Location Transaction types alla. Pole mõtet seda sama mudelit uuesti teha.
Õpetaja: Lõpus peab Vastuse Peab niikuinii saatma sellega ära, et see nagu Nii või naa, vaata siia. Need andmed peavad lõpuks tekkima ühel või teisel viisil. Okei, ee, sobib. Ee, et meil ei ole siis muutujat vaja. Meil ei ole isegi mudelit vaja.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on ainult vaja siia külge lihtsalt panna. Need andmed on ju?
Õpetaja: Aa, siis on uut uut meetodit vaja.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, kus vanad asjad põhimõtteliselt saavad. Otsa, onju? Noh, Näiteks see koht siin.
Õpetaja: Ma võibolla nii palju teeksin. Meil on tegelikult mingi Tehniline võlg on meil veits. Aa, varasemad, kus me toimetanud oleme Tegelikult seal progemise käigus. Nende meetodite järjekord võib olla natukene niimoodi ristirästi
Õpetaja: Aa, Nagu nagu Jumal juhatab. Me peaks tegelt neid korda tegema. Ma praat ei viitsi seda teha. Jätame lihtsalt meelde.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, ma võin du Tuuna selle ka panna on ju et kus me oleme toimetanud. Näiteks, Ee, oleme just toimetanud.
Õpetaja: Ma. Ma ei hakka üle vaatama, lihtsalt panen Siia to do ee. Teejärjekord. Meetodite hierarhia.
Õpetaja: Lähme, Jertz.
Õpetaja: Järjekord Kopin selle ka. Ee, lähen otsin ülesse. Näiteks. Ee, ma arvan, et seal on Äkki enamvähem korras, Aga üle võib ikka vaadata.
Õpetaja: Ja mis veel?
Õpetaja: Oleme toimetanud ka Location Views
Õpetaja: siin. Nii vähe veel Vaatad siia seda ei Pane home. Midagi pole. No, praegult hetkel piisab Mingi hetk. Peaksime viisakalt üle vaatama.
Õpetaja: Tuleme siia. Location View Sse. Kui plaanis on tuua ära Need andmed on ju
Õpetaja: siis, mis võiks olla meetodi nimi?
Õpetaja: Miks see on?
Õpetaja: Võib? Aga mina tahaks isegi parem.
Õpetaja: Sa mõtled transaction vot väga Hea, ma ei oleks jõudnud sinna nii või naa,
Õpetaja: et. Ee. Ärme ütle sellepärast, et kui me lihtsalt tuleks koodis, vaatame nagu.
Õpetaja: Kus on Transaction types Ei, ole.
Õpetaja: Aa sees on transaction Types. Siis see meetodi nimi oleks niivõrd palju parem, kui me sinna ütleme,
Õpetaja: isegi võib tulla Kopida nagu selle on ju, et ee, Get location.
Õpetaja: Noh, selle tee peab suureks täheks tegema. Aga kind see asi match Ib Onju
Õpetaja: et Transaction types sulud. Kui saab parameetreid panna.
Õpetaja: Koodiplokk, kuhu saab koodi kirjutada Meetodi struktuur.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, progesime just natukene aega tagasi ära, nagu selle poole, et sõnum läheb teele. Tahaks nüüd seda kasutada.
Õpetaja: Tts, Mis see Tts? Ee, sümboliseerib.
Õpetaja: Transaction Type Service. Viitame sellele failile, aga ei hakka seda välja kirjutama
Õpetaja: Aitame. Las see veits aitab meid. Lubasin teile, et õpetan, kuidas seda tööriista maksimaalselt hästi kasutada.
Õpetaja: Punktiga Kutsume välja meetodeid, pakub, Et mida tema seal failis näeb. Ja jah, sobib, sobib.
Õpetaja: Kogu see asi return ib meile. Aga ta tegelt juba isegi näitas, et, ee, vähemalt Ta ei näita Voidi
Õpetaja: ta näitab, et ee, midagi tagastab. Ta ei näita, nagu ka ei näita. Tegelikult see tagastab midagi,
Õpetaja: mis ma nüüd siia kirjutan.
Õpetaja: See annab meile promisse objekti, Vaata, mis? Lubab, et ühel hetkel tuleb vastus temaga. Tahaks toimetada selle objektiga,
Õpetaja: mis meetodid on, mis siis, saab ee. Aktsias meie ees käivitada?
Õpetaja: Jah, Teen Catch Finali Teen Catch.
Õpetaja: Loomulikult ei kirjuta enam koodi. Ee, niimoodi. Ee, Horisontaalselt vasakult paremale, vaid
Õpetaja: hakkame seda asja viima. Niimoodi üksteise alla.
Õpetaja: Teenblokk, Millal käivitud?
Õpetaja: Kui Catch Blog käivitab, räägime Htp staatustest. Käivitab
Õpetaja: ilmselt kahesajaga võib niimoodi öelda. Need teised informatiivsed asjad. Ma isegi ei tea, kuidas täpselt käi. Käitub nagu et kakssada. Peab ikka saama kuidagi lõpuks
Õpetaja: ja Catch tuleb, käivitub. Kui on staatused nelisada viissada Midagi
Õpetaja: Nüüd siia sisse, siis saab kirjutada niukest Landa Funktsiooni anonüümne käivitamine. Aga sellisel viisil, et me saame Defineerida muutuja nime. Ee, joonistada siia, joonistada, Kirjutada siia noole võrdusmärk ja nurga abil.
Õpetaja: Control tühik. Call Comput annab ette meile väikse põhja
Õpetaja: välju. Meile ei meeldi. Meile meeldiks ju, et oleks sildikese nimi. Opees.
Õpetaja: Response on siis kogu vastus koos sulgejate karvadega? No Neid seda pildiseeriat üle ei pane. Võite uuesti vaadata Pärast Slack Ist.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Meil on kokku lepitud süsteem, et meie Handley, nagu seda asja koodi mõttes siin, selles Samas meetodis vaid delegeerime selle tegevuse edasi. Kuidas
Õpetaja: Ei, ole, vend? Ee, selle,
Õpetaja: mis me praegu teeme. Me teeme nüüd niiöelda programmeerimise võtet, et Me kirjutame niiöelda koodi, kus me kutsume välja meetodi, mida tegelikult veel ei ole olemas.
Õpetaja: Kuna tasub siin selles koodifailis. See meetod edaspidi siis on This. Nüüd on vaja mõelda mingisugune meetodi nimi. Oleme Selles ka juba oma mustriga kokku leppinud. Kuidas see Käib? Et
Õpetaja: jah, siin. Võibolla Niimoodi võib isegi copida seda
Õpetaja: ja paste ida selle ja lihtsalt kirjutada handle ette, onju?
Õpetaja: Ja see panna suureks keeks, mitte fiks transaction types, Aga midagi veel Tulude ressurss ei ole. Veel suruda Respons
Õpetaja: siia meetodi nimesse. Ka ikkagi. Et millega on probleem? Mis, Mis, millega sa tegeled
Õpetaja: nüüd sulgude sisse. Paneme respons. Miks me peame viitama järsku sellele mu sildikesele? Siin?
Õpetaja: Mis me peame Siis me tahame anda seda responsi sellele meetodile. Mida me välja kutsume kaasa. Kui infona.
Õpetaja: Kui seda ei tee, siis see lihtsalt läheb kaduma.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on paras hetk.
Õpetaja: Noh, Andrus, sul See asi ei tööta. Im so sorry, aga ma. Okei, ma näitan, kuidas sa saad siin ise ruttu teha, Vaata onju?
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt, võta see osa siit.
Õpetaja: Tule, Copy.
Õpetaja: Nimetame siia peale tagasi.
Õpetaja: Sul on. Oota sulle valesti kert. Pane suure tähega
Õpetaja: proovida. Ikka, et äkki saab vä?
Õpetaja: Jah, Nii seekord tuli. No väga hea, Tegite ära, on ju? Oi, mis siin tuli? Et vaata Korra tuli.
Õpetaja: Kukkus kuskile siia. Alla,
Õpetaja: vajutan entrit, Entrit. See return on The Fine. Tema ei tea. Võibolla tahab midagi taga. Ei taha.
Õpetaja: Nüüd oli Missioon oli ju see, et Ee,
Õpetaja: Handle Get location Transaction types response, et me soovime seda vastust.
Õpetaja: Seda andmeid siit, Mis see teenus meile tagastab?
Õpetaja: Soovime panna siia vastatajale Thats the plan.
Õpetaja: Ja Ma kirjutan siis
Õpetaja: siis iga Alustame ikka. Jah, Foutation Location.
Õpetaja: See on praegult see, et puudutame justkui seda silti ja seda objekti Hetkel süsteemist loetakse justkui väärtust, kui tahaks kuskil seda kasutada. Aga me ei taha seda lugeda. Väärtust vaid
Õpetaja: võrdub. Jah, võrdusmärgiga Anname uue asja.
Õpetaja: Respons, punkt. Valu ei ole.
Õpetaja: Vaatan Jah, totta.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi saame kätte ilma nende sulgudeta. Ta siin tab. Iga tahab valida mingit imelikku asja, mis Iganes su ei ole
Õpetaja: toota
Õpetaja: ja rohkem tegelikult midagi pole.
Õpetaja: Idee järgi oleks saanud kogu selle asja ka siia panna, siis eksole,
Õpetaja: kui tahaks, Aga me ei tee seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii,
Õpetaja: Catch. I Võime ka ära teha. Siin see teenus ühtegi. Ee, niiöelda. Ee, defineeritud viga ei tagasta, Aga alati võib status Viissada internal server. Error võib tulla. Telekat öeldes tuleme. Seda Koolis on midagi katki. Või Mis iganes, tuleb mingisugused
Õpetaja: siseseid vigu. Vaata, mida ei ole. Nagu ära programmeeritud. Nagu teie enda poolt. Et näed, tuleb igal sellistel tingimustel ehk siis Catch I peaks alati panema selle, et
Õpetaja: tema pakub, et üks uus muutuja nimi, mingi tegevus meil tegelikult sisuliselt on ülisavi Lihtsalt kui tuleb mingi viga, me tahame öelda,
Õpetaja: mis me tahame öelda? Saada kasutaja uks. Läks midagi valesti.
Õpetaja: Jah, Ns Navigation Service Punkt Navigate to Error See ikka jääb
Õpetaja: Gat Location Transaction Types. Meetode nime puhul võib praegu midagi märgata. Mida on seal märgata?
Õpetaja: Hall on? See tähendab seda, et
Õpetaja: pole kasutusel. Keegi mind ei Taha on ju,
Õpetaja: kus? Tahame seda ka välja kutsuda.
Õpetaja: Kui leht laetakse, ehk siis
Õpetaja: jah. By the way on see et, lõpetab nagu mingi Transaction I Ära läheb uuele reale ja nii edasi. Kui te olete lihtsalt mistahes real ja teil on vaja tulla siia uus rida teha Niimoodi, bla blabla. Mis iganes
Õpetaja: Aa kuskile tahate tekitada, siis lihtsalt shift enter. Ma kasutan seda all The time Shift Enter lihtsalt teeb uue Rea siia alla ja paneb. Oi, ära Ära jama.
Õpetaja: Aa, shift. End. Ei, oota. Ja ma ütlesin. Control Shift endaga. Tahtsin niimoodi panna. Ma Näitan seda ka. Vaata, et ei ole tühja rida. Olen siin keskel. Ma ei taha niimoodi lüüa. On ju
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt entredit Ei taha lüüa, Ei, viitsi ka seda, et lähen siia lõppu. Vajutan, sest, et see võtab mul lihtsalt. Aa.
Õpetaja: See lihtsalt põletab minu sõrmeliigeseid Shift enter. Noh, See põletab natukene vähem.
Õpetaja: Ei ole vaja kahte trikki teha.
Õpetaja: Siit siis kutsume välja.
Õpetaja: Siin asuvad meetodid. Mis asi oli Get Occasion Transaction types sulud. Paneme ka, et saab, aru, et tegemist on meetodiga.
Õpetaja: Käivitan meetodid.
Õpetaja: No ja nüüd peaks juba tegelikult see asi toimima, kuidas saab kontrollida Noh, kuidagi Brauseris.
Õpetaja: Ee, võin korra teha ka komitee. Kas tuleb keegi järgi või ei tule
Õpetaja: praegu keegi kätte Püsti ei pesnud, aga ma Pean Comiti igal juhul ära. Ja push I ka. Vajutan seda nuppu. Aa,
Õpetaja: et, ee. Kui minna nüüd sellele lehele
Õpetaja: ja teha lahti, Noh, Teeme siis siit selle mugavamalt, et kui mul
Õpetaja: Location I Citys tuuakse ära kenasti ja näeme, et
Õpetaja: transaction types on ka kenasti ära toodud,
Õpetaja: on toodud.
Õpetaja: Järjekord on siin vale. Vaata, Isabelovi on eespool ja nii edasi. Aga seal ei ole Absoluutselt vahet.
Õpetaja: Võtab selle järjekorra siis päris Vastuse korra pulli pärast proovin Svägerit.
Õpetaja: Private out.
Õpetaja: Huvitav, et ta näitab teistpidi, sest siin järjekord on ju korrektne.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole Ei, huvita,
Õpetaja: sellepärast Ongi võti väärtus. Vaata, et need asjad võivad olla mistahes järjekorras. Me ei ütle, et mine võta muutu ühest üks ja siis mine Võta Midagi muutu. Ühest kaks, Vaid me viitame võtmetele, onju? Ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Sellega on nüüd niimoodi, et. Ee. Nüüd nende andmete pealt, mis meil nüüd siia sisse tulevad
Õpetaja: need samad. Selle järgi peaks nüüd kuvama siin kõikvõimalikud Transaction Ee, taipeid Checkbox Id.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma mõtlen, et vahelduseks Teeme siis teistpidi. Vaata, et kirjutame koodi niiöelda siia ja hakkame seda ekstrakti maja viima allapoole, et meil oleks ka nagu see kogemus.
Õpetaja: No Me oleme seda natuke teinud, aga teeme veel,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, Okei, andmed on meil siin kenasti olemas. Ee, väga tore.
Õpetaja: No kui me mõtleme, et meil on siit ee, vaja mingisugust uut asja, mis võiks olla esimene mõte
Õpetaja: ja milleks leiutada kõiki neid varjundeid ja Howerdamisi ja linkimisi Ja mida iganes,
Õpetaja: võtame selle kuskilt lihtsalt. No mul on siin vana tabiga lahti. Veel.
Õpetaja: Ee, siia. Checkbox I research. I kirjutame checks.
Õpetaja: Need ei ole nüüd tšekid. Vaata, nagu, et ee. Ma teate, vanasti sai raha selle niimoodi anda
Õpetaja: kirjutasid tšeki. Need on nagu kontrollid ka enda
Õpetaja: Ja nendest kastidest. Põhimõtteliselt meil see sama esimene sobibki.
Õpetaja: The Full Checkbox Noh, mingeid vahepealseid näitajaid on ka, Vaata, et sa saad panna talle Kriipsu. Vaata
Õpetaja: Radio Patronit. Vaatame hiljem teed. Trade. Vaata need meie tööd. Sa ei vaatagi, aga pole midagi erilist
Õpetaja: No tegelikult. Ee. Checkboxil See on nüüd Swiches. See tegelikult on ikkagi checkbox. Tal on lihtsalt disain teistsugune.
Õpetaja: Äkki ostame hoopis neid vä Väga Fancy. Jah, aitäh.
Õpetaja: Nii äge. Mulle meeldib täiega nagu vanakooli värk on. Aga sellel as Sellel asjal on ka muidugi nagu jah, segamini niikuinii. Ja. Ja. Ja mis asi See on
Õpetaja: Native Switch Haptics, Mis ta teeb?
Õpetaja: Ei päriseb. Või Noh, siin on midagi muud juba. Ee, võtame Switchi.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis Scrollige see Switch ide all ära ja võtke lihtsalt see esimene näide. Will Figure.
Õpetaja: Jah, ta ei ole ka. Mäletad? Kui me tegime seda meest, Naine, Vaata, Siis meil pidi olema ühine atribuut. Kuidas tal saab aru? Vaata, mis. Nagu Reidi Ja pattanid on seotud. Sest seal, käitumine on see Üks või teine,
Õpetaja: Aga siin on see, et. Noh, lülita need sisse ja välja. Mis Tahad, Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Okei, ee. Võtame selle näite. Tuleme, Otsime siis ee praegult. Kuhu seda panna? Siin, selles.
Õpetaja: No siin, kus meil on see Location Forum Ega meil hetkel muud varianti pole kui lihtsalt siia alla panna.
Õpetaja: Plaan on ta pärast Location Forum I sisse viia, on nii?
Õpetaja: Saame siin selle asja tööle väga omale säärasest
Õpetaja: väga vales ääres vä sest. Et see kolle ei kolle. Pärast on ta vasakul ilmselt. On
Õpetaja: jah. Kuule. Ma, ei viitsi temaga jagada okei. Võtame, kontorisse, et Teeme ta siis, Ee,
Õpetaja: teeme. Paneme ta siis õigesse kohta ära. Nii, kus ta olema peab? No ta peab olema igal vormi sees. See on selge.
Õpetaja: Ta on osav vormist.
Õpetaja: Oota, tuleme siis siia. Vormi otsime ära. Kus on viimane input ja paneme ta siia järgi Mõned tühjad read ka, et lihtsalt, et on mugavam Ja vaadata. On ju, et
Õpetaja: siin on see Location I viimane kast, See on ju Tema järgi paneme selle plöraki maha. No nüüd, ta võiks seal vähemalt.
Õpetaja: Noh, enamvähem on. Vaata, tekst kipub natuke paremal pool olema. Seda saab Csiga niiöelda Timmida.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Aa, okei, Kohe vaatame, nagu seda edasi, et ta ette siia saime. Siit võib mõned asjad juba ära koristada.
Õpetaja: See Four Label. Tegelikult ei ole otseselt vajalik, et kustutame ära. Input ilt endalt Id.
Õpetaja: Ta oleks kena, kui ta seal oleks vaata jaadi jaadi Ja aga siis on siin üks probleem. Vaata, saab olla ainult ühe korra
Õpetaja: lehel. Aga kui neid tuleb kokku kolm, siis on nagu, et Kas Igal ühel on nagu Id? Vaata, mida me peame hakkama ka manageerima. Ei ole vaja, neid.
Õpetaja: Ei ole vaja neid.
Õpetaja: Siis võtame Id, Võtame input ist ära
Õpetaja: ja labelist võtame. Siis viite sellele Id Le, mis me just ära kustutasime.
Õpetaja: Ee, siia. Paneme lihtsalt praegu lühendatult. Ee, nimi. Lihtsalt korra, nagu saada. Nagu ta mingi normaalseks ette Nimi
Õpetaja: Mm, siia. Class ülesse. Vaadake, kuidas need nupud elavad. Meil Aa, kaelas.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult Seda teeme natuke teistpidi, sest et me saame vormile panna. Selle paneme ikka kohe ära siia,
Õpetaja: et ütleme, et hoia minust eemale. Kuidas seda Sai kogu see kupatus. Ütleme, et kõik, mis tuleb peale mind allpool. Hoia vahet
Õpetaja: margin. Bottom. Eelmine kord seda mingi margin. Bottom Nelja vist Oleme enamus ajast kasutanud. Siis on natukene. Nad hoiavad üksteisest eemale.
Õpetaja: Aa, siin on nüüd see, et teksti paika saada. Mina ei mäleta, kuidas See on mingi tekst.
Õpetaja: Tekst Tart.
Õpetaja: Noh, nimi. Vaata, see tekst nagu tuli siia vasakule, poole
Õpetaja: siis vastukaaluks. Nagu tekst enda oleks
Õpetaja: elipsis Oi, Mis end vot? See on? Lihtsalt see tekstipaigutus Selles võimalus saate ära, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, seda ma paneks lihtsalt niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Natukene lihtsalt endale. Lihtsalt nagu Visuaalselt parem Nii nimi. Nüüd Point on siis see, et, ee, see asi peab tulema nüüd andmete pealt,
Õpetaja: kui me vaatame praegult korra Ee, View a tegelt. Sellega saab ka vist veits seda vaadata. Ma ei tea, kas saab või ei saa,
Õpetaja: Seda saab väiksemaks ka natukene teha saab. Location View on kõik. See, ee, roheline ala on onju?
Õpetaja: Location Viewel on oma Child Location Forum On see osa,
Õpetaja: et nüüd ongi See, et andmed on jälle meil siin.
Õpetaja: Aga andmed peavad tulema. Siia Alla välja. Location form. Ile on arusaadav.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: Aa kurat, siia tuleb kokku neid tegelikult. Ee. Praeguse näite puhul tuleb seda kolm korda, on nii?
Õpetaja: Peaks tulema. No, kui ma korra teen, ärge seda praegult Ee, Teie Siis tehke. Ma duubeldan. Duubeldan ühe korra. Veel.
Õpetaja: Lõpptulemus on plaanis Selline enamvähem.
Õpetaja: Mm, näeme, nüüd, et margin. Bottom mängib meile veits Macra,
Õpetaja: Ee, sellepärast, et iga see element ütleks, et ole sina teisest eemal On ju? Juba selle asja nägime ära, aga plaan on põhimõtteliselt selline, et meil tuleb kolm nuppu.
Õpetaja: Nüüd
Õpetaja: meie mõte on, et see. See kõik oleks üks eraldi komponent, Kui me praegu teeks sellest eraldi komponendi, tekib üks väike probleem, mis probleem tekib,
Õpetaja: kui kogu see osa läheb eraldi komponendiks ja läheb template sisse, Mis probleem tekib?
Õpetaja: Jah
Õpetaja: mõte on see. Vaata, kui see asi nüüd läheb uude blokki ja läheb templeid vahele, siis seal on kolm child i templateis. Peab alati olema ainult Üks Child
Õpetaja: mõeldud niimoodi. Ehk siis juba ettenägelikult. Me võime teha, niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Et Esiteks, me koristame selle Mb nelja ära. Me tegeleme sellega. Hiljem
Õpetaja: Kogu see asi võiks minna veel eraldi divi sisse, sest et dünaamiliselt tuleb neid. Jumal teab, kui palju neid elemente ja me ei taha, Et genereeritud variandis templateis on nagu kindla. Mitu sisu ma olen seda küsinud Nii ja naa. Ma Ei, mäleta. Mida Chat sellest arvas, aga Meie teeme igal juhul niimoodi, et me ütleme, et on div.
Õpetaja: Me lahendame ka ära. Siis selle margin potem teema ära. Me teeme ühe Tv juurde.
Õpetaja: Teeme siia veits ruumi ja nüüd tõstame kogu selle kupatuse. Lihtsalt selle ekstra devideri sisse
Õpetaja: Noh, siin. Nüüd saame teha niimoodi, et Isegi ma teen seda. Ärge teie tehke. Ma teen kaks siia. Tublid, et hetkel on nad niimoodi. Ei ole üksteisega koos,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd on Need nupud elavad seljas, et siis see ülemine diff siia. Me saamegi nagu teha selle. Et. Hei, kui minule midagi tuleb järgi,
Õpetaja: siis me Ütleme, et hoia minust eemale. Siis me saavutame selle, et need on omavahel ikkagi koos. Aga nupud hoiavad eemale. Saate mõttest aru,
Õpetaja: sest et Nüüd on see suhe neil selline.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma pakun, et, ee. Nüüd võiks olla siis see hetk. Vaata, kus meil on Niukene seis, et Meil on siis üks nupp. Teeme sellest eraldi Child I.
Õpetaja: Ma oleks võinud täiesti vabalt käsitsi teha kogu selle asja. Aga Ee, jah
Õpetaja: või Jah, ei tea, joonistame. Teeme natukene lihtsamaks oma elu, et ikkagi lahendame ära, et siin visuaalselt tekiks neid kokku kolm tükki
Õpetaja: Esiteks on vaja andmeid hetkel praegult siia. Sellesse keskmisesse. Laps. Ee, Child. I. Niiöelda see panen kõiki kinni. Ei pane.
Õpetaja: Meil on siin Ee location ee.
Õpetaja: Aa, Ma tahan sellesse järjekorda panna, et meil on Location View. Meil on Location Forum. Kus hetkel see child Istub? Aa, teeme selle ära, et Me saaksime siin kätte. Need andmed,
Õpetaja: mis istuvad siin Transaction typesis.
Õpetaja: Aga minu pakkumine on see, et ärme tee niimoodi, et me anname ainult siia Transaction types sellele vormile kaasa
Õpetaja: vaid. Anname kogu Location objekti kaasa.
Õpetaja: Aga need Id meil läheb seda niikuinii vaja.
Õpetaja: Siis me tuleme Location Forum I.
Õpetaja: Mis me siin siis muudame? Et oleks võimalik objekti siia sisse saada. Kosena
Õpetaja: Uus Props, onju, et hetkel on ainult võimalik siia
Õpetaja: kaasa anda. City S on ju? See on see väärtus A. Nüüd ütleme, et ei, Ei,
Õpetaja: Siia on võimalik kaasa anda location
Õpetaja: ja kuna Ta on. Objekt. Saab lühikeselt teha. Niimoodi,
Õpetaja: aga oleks ka võimalik teha niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Mulle meeldib siis hoida kandja seda stiili. Ee, kuskil keegi vaidleks vastu. Ilmselt saab ka ju
Õpetaja: lühemalt. Miks sa nii ei tee?
Õpetaja: Nüüd Esialgu lahendame selle mure. Ära Vaata, et päriselt Location andmed tuleksid siia Propsist, et hetkel, kui te Refresh E vaadata, siis ee. Peaks olema. Ma ei tea, null, või mida iganes,
Õpetaja: Ee, tegelt, mis ma selle teen. Teeme siit selle poega, et kui praegult vaadata, et. Ee, jah, meil nüüd on siin. Ee, selles
Õpetaja: Sellel, ee, võimekus võtta vastu midagi, sisse, aga ta ei saa midagi,
Õpetaja: sest me lõime võimekuse. Aga see koht, kus Location View kutsub Location Forum I välja. Hetkel ta annab kaasa. Ainult City S andmed.
Õpetaja: Mis me siis teeme, on see, et läheme tagasi Location Use.
Õpetaja: Otsime ülesse selle, koha, kus Location Forum välja kutsutakse. Mis on siin?
Õpetaja: Hetkel Öeldakse, et alla antakse kaasa Ainult Citys.
Õpetaja: Mis me siia kirjutame? Mis ma kirjutan siia,
Õpetaja: ta on, ta on anda nüüd tegelikult kogu Location objekti alla kaasa. Kuidas ma teen seda? Võimekus on olemas, mis ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Kool on
Õpetaja: nüüd. Ta järsku näitab, et. Kuule, sa pole veel, et seal on Niukene Props Nagu Location. Sa pole nagu sellele veel viidanud.
Õpetaja: Äkki tahad midagi anda? Sinna?
Õpetaja: Nüüd Ma kirjutan siia, võrdub.
Õpetaja: Ja mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Location Ehk siis Põhimõtteliselt, et anna need andmed, mis meil on siin Data blokis, kus Sulgede ja karvadega
Õpetaja: ole hea.
Õpetaja: Annan need siia,
Õpetaja: Okei, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Kontrollida Saame, kui ma teen Refresh I ja vaatan seda Location View d Location Views on need Transaction Type Id. Ei, ole
Õpetaja: huvitav, kas me saime sulle juba tööle Ei saanud? Vä Ee, Refresh.
Õpetaja: Teeme ju ära. Andmed. Transaction Type andmed ei tähenda.
Õpetaja: Jäi poolikuks. Vä Mina ka ei mäleta. Enam on ikka ei tahtnud tuua.
Õpetaja: Tulevad need andmed? Stopline ilt tulevad.
Õpetaja: Nüüd vaatame, kas nad ujuvad alla. Propsina ka.
Õpetaja: Tundub, et ujuvad.
Õpetaja: No need asjad siin ei ole mingit sisu, aga transaction types voolas alla vastutajale.
Õpetaja: Okei, nüüd on hea koht. Ee, kus me saame Location forumil teha seda, et ütleme, et
Õpetaja: Aa veel ei ole, Teeme selle ka ära, et nüüd vastavalt nendele andmetele, siis kuvatakse neid valikuid.
Õpetaja: On ju siis minu. Küsimus teile on, et kui siin, on, siis see Kogu kupatus
Õpetaja: Siin on siis see üks. Ja see ainus. Niiöelda checkbox praegu, mis on Switchi kujul.
Õpetaja: Kui me tahame nüüd donaamiliselt saada seda Mitu korda
Õpetaja: siis? Mis tööriist meil appi tõta?
Õpetaja: Four loop. Aga kuidas ta siin selles voes on?
Õpetaja: Ee, before. Kuhu tuleb Before kirjutada
Õpetaja: kivi sisse, et siin tuleb lihtsalt mõelda. Vaata siis seda, et mis, Mida hõlmab, onju, et mis on see osa? Vaata, mis on see element, Mida me tahame hakata? Nagu duubeldama, et. No ma teen korra näite nagu. Vaata, et kas me tahame, et see oleks
Õpetaja: niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Bresh ei oska seda isegi kuvada. Või?
Õpetaja: Noh, okei, panen Id siis Näiteks nimi Nimi Nimi Piibi.
Õpetaja: Huvitav, et seda input I nagu ei suuda teha, See on täitsa huvitav kohe, aga saate mõttest aru Vaata, meil on vaja aru saada. Vaata, et mis on mille sees ja mida me Tahame niiöelda. Siis korrata. Ilmselt on ikka siis See See osa siin on ju?
Õpetaja: Ehk siis on see, mida peaks siis dünaamiliselt tegema? Ehk Siis see W. Four peaks tulema siia sisse, Before.
Õpetaja: Noh, võibolla kirjutab selle foor välja.
Õpetaja: Pole ammu seda tsüklit teinud,
Õpetaja: Ei, mäleta? Täpselt kuidas kirjutada. Mis see süntaks on? Aga meil oli väikene mõtteviis. Kuidas jõuda tulemuseni.
Õpetaja: Küsimärk on küsimärk.
Õpetaja: Küsimärk In Küsimärk.
Õpetaja: Mis Paremale poole peab, Ee, tulema viide mingi kollektsioonile onju?
Õpetaja: Mis meil on See kollektsioon siin selles Location form aeg. Noh,
Õpetaja: Ahah, väga hea. Nipiga küsimuse eest.
Õpetaja: Transaction types Oli meil transaction types.
Õpetaja: Mhmh
Õpetaja: ahah.
Õpetaja: Et kas vastab tõele? No seda mudelit me kahjuks siin defineerida ei saa. Mudel on defineeritud meil parenties, et Location sees on niuksed, andmed ja Transaction type sees on Sellised andmed, onju? Ja päriselt tegelikult seal objektis ka on, on ju,
Õpetaja: et Nüüd me peame minema niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: see kollektsioon on Location I sees. Aga ta ei ole see Location objekt ise, on ju?
Õpetaja: Mis ma Siis kirjutan siia Aidake mind.
Õpetaja: Küsimus Location punkt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi, et vahel ta kuidagi väga hästi saab aru. Ee, see mudel ei ole siin selles samas failis.
Õpetaja: Siis kui vigu ei taha teha siis sa võid minna lihtsalt ja copida siit, aga võid ka käsitsi selle kirjutada, Aga Ta kahjuks seda praegult Hetkel ei paku meile ise. Sellepärast, et see mudel on kuskil mujal.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd on meil tsüklil olemas parem, pool,
Õpetaja: kust tulevad niiöelda kõik. Ee, niiöelda. Siis tuleb mingi massiiv,
Õpetaja: mis siia vasakule poole peab minema.
Õpetaja: Ainsus. Aga mis asi See on See Ainsus, mis asi see on?
Õpetaja: Seda küll aitäh. Aga mis Ta on oma olemas? Et mis asi see on siin koodi osana? Vaata, mis asi on.
Õpetaja: No kuidas
Õpetaja: ta ei ole Massiiv? Ee, massiiv on. Esiteks seal paremal pool, Aga Lihtsalt kui ma üritan öelda, vaata, et mis, Mis asi ta nagu on, Siis ma ikka kaitsen veel ühte sõna. Kas ta mu olemuselt on
Õpetaja: objekti?
Õpetaja: Ei ole objekt, aga juba teine ütles vähemalt õige asja. Muutuja. Meil on vaja niimoodi. Vaata, et see kood taustal saab toimetada niimoodi et tema võtab objekte siit sellest, ee, Niiöelda sellest massiivist.
Õpetaja: Ja igal igal tsüklil. Ta seob selle mingisuguse sildiga ehk muutujaga.
Õpetaja: Noh, see vastus oli õige. Keegi juba siin ütles ka Vaata, tuleb sinna kirjutada. No, teel on lihtsalt vaja aru saada, Mis asi see on Siin See on muutuja igal tsüklil.
Õpetaja: Noh, täitsa
Õpetaja: Ja Ta Ei, otsi seda muutujat. Mm, kas kas see kõik? Kas asi laguneks laiali, kui ma panen siia praegu? Xx
Õpetaja: ei lagune, see töötab ikka kogu aeg. Sest et see on lihtsalt silt.
Õpetaja: Igal tsüklil võetakse üks objekt transaction typessivist Ja seotakse sellel konkreetsel tsüklil selle nime nimega, Mis ma siia panen? Ma Võingi panna lihtsalt. Ma ei tea. T tähtes
Õpetaja: palu väga töötab.
Õpetaja: Ta ei võta. See ei ole seotud nende Nimedega see ei ole. See nimi võib olla mida iganes
Õpetaja: Ta võib olla, mida iganes, absoluutselt, mida iganes. Aga meil on loomulikult mõistlik
Õpetaja: et, Ta repressendib, et mis siin on. Siin on üks Transaction Type tsüklil ja nüüd me saame temaga toimetada.
Õpetaja: Ee, saame. Saame lahti kõigepealt sellest Ee, asjast, et ta vajab enda jaoks Ghid.
Õpetaja: Mäletate praegult? Ta tahab hakata põhimõtteliselt. Kogu seda parema korra siit näidata.
Õpetaja: Ee, mitte inspekt ja Tegelikult inspekt saab, ka, et tausta Parem on ikkagi nagu näide. Ee, Teen korra Network. Teen Refresh, et taustal tuuakse ära need andmed,
Õpetaja: igal tsüklil. Ta võtab ühe objekti ja seob selle selle Ainsuses Transaction Type muutujaga.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Point on see et tema, ise peaks kogu aeg jälgima, Et Millal ta peab uuesti Html I renderdama? Millal Ta peab pildi uuesti joonistama? Ta peab jälgima neid muudatusi, mis siin objektide sees on, Aga kui meie anname nagu terve objekti, nagu niiöelda muutuste jälgimiseks? Tal võib tekkida raskusi,
Õpetaja: võib tekkida raskusi arusaama, et millal on mingi muutus Toimund. Eriti kui nad on mingid massiivsed ja suured. Näiteks pildid ja asjad, et millal muutus toimub? Nüüd meil on ee nagu selline tehniline nõue, et meie peaksime täpsustama ära, et kas siin sees on mingisugune väärtus,
Õpetaja: Mis on selles mõttes iga objekti kohta unikaalne,
Õpetaja: mida teraselt saab Voe jälgida muutuste mõttes, et kui ta märkab muutusi. See on nüüd see Key asi. Me tahame panna atribuudi iga kord voor tsükli, siis Me tahame öelda, Voele, et Kuule, ära vaata tervet objekti. Kas siin on mingeid muudatusi? Vaid vaata lihtsalt
Õpetaja: Ja vaata, ta peab siis ainult meeles hoidma. Enda Üks, kaks ja kolm. Ja nüüd jälgima. Vaata, et kas mingi hetk taustal Ee, olukord muutub. Kus objektide sees on? Hoopis Üks, kolm, kaks või üks, kaks, kolm, neli, Lihtsalt üks
Õpetaja: üks ja kaks. Vahet pole, ta peab lihtsalt jälgima ainult väikest osa sellest objektist Muutuste osas Võti. Võti, mille järgi mina juhind, on, Kas on vaja uuesti renderdada või mitte saadakse aru. See süsteem on tehtud niimoodi et Andmete pealt kohe ise. Kogu aeg. Igal pool jälgib.
Õpetaja: Kas on vaja joonistada uuesti või ei ole vaja joonistada uuesti. On vaja joonistada Uuesti Või Ei ole vaja Kõik need tabelid värgid. You name It whatever. Ta vaatab ise neid sündmusi aga Siin ongi lihtsalt see, et need Objektid võivad olla mida iganes
Õpetaja: ja võibolla keeruline. Siis on hea, kui sa annad talle lihtsalt ainult ühe välja, mida ta peab vaatama, Ta suudab seda palju paremini teha. Ideaalis. Need peaksid olema kõik erinevad väärtused iga objekti kohta. Ideaalis, Nad võiksid olla täiesti unikaalsed Ideaalis võiksid olla Need numbrilised väärtused,
Õpetaja: Kuna nendega on programmiliselt väga kiire võimalik seal taustal toimetada, ehk siis meile sobib need relatsioonilised andmebaasi väärtused,
Õpetaja: need Id, D, Okei,
Õpetaja: ee, selge, väga hea. Siis lähemegi siia tagasi ja ütleme, et meil on see We Four Paneme praegu lausa tal kõrvale
Õpetaja: atribuut, Paneme juba kooloniga, et saaks kuskilt ee võtta. Nagu objektist Ghee.
Õpetaja: Ja Nüüd meie ütleme selle muutuja nime Abil me pöördume objekti poole. Ei Transaction Type
Õpetaja: Transaction selle ühe objekti seest. Tuleme siia. Üks objekt. Ole hea. Vaata, Transaction Type Id punkt.
Õpetaja: Tema ei ole. Ei paku, miks ta Ei paku, sest, et mudel ei ole siin failis.
Õpetaja: Noh, läks valesti.
Õpetaja: Kõige kindlam oleks praegult siin teha niimoodi et korra lihtsalt põikad sinna pärandisse. Kus see mudel on? Tuled Vaatad siit niimoodi? Kopiga Põmm
Õpetaja: tuled. Location for Me ja paned siia põmm.
Õpetaja: Ee, Mul vist läks nüüd kuskilt katki, et mul jutumärk kadus ära. Vot niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Iga Fordsükli juures tuleb ära määrata mingi pisikene Osa sellest objektist, mida voe jälgib muutuste mõttes.
Õpetaja: Kui üks, kaks, kolm on esialgne seis. Ta jätab selle meelde. Järsku andmed taustal muutuvad, et on üks, kaks, kolm, neli, siis ta teab
Õpetaja: vaja uuesti trenderdada.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas see on nii peenelt. Optimeerib ka, et siis ta ainult selle osa renderdab uuesti, mis tuli juurde või vähemaks. Ja ta lihtsalt. Kogu selle tsükli teeb uuesti läbi ja seda ma ei tea. Pole vahet, ei huvita,
Õpetaja: põhiline asi on See, et nüüd on meil olemas
Õpetaja: renderdust kolmest. Aa, nii öelda objektist.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on see, et hetkel on staatiliselt nendel kõigil see nimi
Õpetaja: Me Ei, taha, et oleks nimi.
Õpetaja: Me tahaksime, et oleks Transaction Type. Name siis siia.
Õpetaja: Kuidas Ma saan nüüd järsku siia öelda, et et Võta,
Õpetaja: Võta selle objekti. Transaction Type Name,
Õpetaja: et ma praegu tühjus onju? Kuidas Ma saan nagu, et siia tuleks, siis sellest andmed, mis seal Taustal on tegelikult olemas, et palun sealt igalt objektilt tema rea kohta. Võta, lihtsalt transaction type name
Õpetaja: Mm, Topelt loogilised sulud miks ja mis on?
Õpetaja: Ja sest kui me hakkame praegu lihtsalt kirjutama Transaction Type, siis ta mõtleb, et. Ahah tekst. Palun väga, mul, on, ee.
Õpetaja: Mõtlen, et See sisu tuleb kuskilt muud ajast.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me viitamegi igalt tsüklilt samamoodi, kust me võtame? Nagu et ühe objekti tema transaction type id oli Niiöelda konkreetsel ühel tsüklil. Ee võtmeks. Nüüd Me ütleme, et Transaction Type
Õpetaja: punkt jälle Kahjuks ei paku siin väga palju asju aga mudeli saab siit kätte.
Õpetaja: Me teame, et seal on Niukene Väli Transaction Type Name. Kopime selle, Paneme pungiga.
Õpetaja: Kui kui te ei tea, kui te ei tea. Vaata, mis seal sees oli. Te võite teha selle triki ka, et pange siis lihtsalt see Transaction type Korraks kuvatakse Jasonit
Õpetaja: siit saate ka copida. Ja ei, ma ei taha tervet objekti sinna. Selleks nimeks tahan ainult seda.
Õpetaja: Ahah, okei,
Õpetaja: Niukene. Lihtne work around või ei viitsi seda. Noh, kas sa vajutasid korra? Tab i vahet või läksid Browser Isse, et sa pead niikuinii klõbistama midagi et selles mõttes suurt vahet pole. Mina võtaks isiklikult alati mudelist. Kuigi siin on ka argument. Vaata Alati vaata, et miks võiks vaadata Hoopis tegelikult seda sisu korraks,
Õpetaja: äkki Kui on pugi, vaatab, Mudel on valesti defineeritud. Siis see korra näeb vähemalt õigeid väärtusi.
Õpetaja: Mis tegelikkuse taga on? See Mudel ei tähenda mitte Midagi See siin ei tähenda Selles mõttes Mitte ööd ega mütsi. Tegelikud andmed tulevad ikka teenusega. Mäleta kus ta tuleb? Teenusega
Õpetaja: Siit tuleb teenusega, et Dislocation Transaction types tuleb teenuse teenuse niiöelda andmetest,
Õpetaja: et mis sealt tuleb? Mis võtmetega Seal on? On tegelikult taustal mudel võib selles mõttes valetada.
Õpetaja: Aga teie loomulikult arendate niimoodi, et tegu ei tule.
Õpetaja: No nüüd saab vaadata raha sisse raha välja. Maksed sobib
Õpetaja: nüüd meile. Tegelikult tuleb Ee, sisse andmed. Kui vaadata seda vaadata korra andmetele otsa,
Õpetaja: siis ee. Transaction Type ides on väärtused Kõigil
Õpetaja: aga meil on praegu siin. Ee,
Õpetaja: Nad Justkui ei ole veel sidunud seda ära. Me oleme sidunud selle ära, et. Hei, tuleb Nii palju neid Checkbox Ey. Kõigi nimed tulevad Transaction Type Name ist. Igaühe taga on Id, mida me visuaalselt ei näe, aga on olemas transaction type. Noh, korra saab tõestada ka, vaata, et ma panen korra siia. See on vaatamise koht.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma panen näiteks siia. Kirjutan Id Callon. Panen loogilised sulud. Ütlen, ee, selle sama asja. Ee, Key. Panen lihtsalt
Õpetaja: mitte Id, vaid pane näiteks ghee Korraks sulgudes.
Õpetaja: Ei, me ei pane rohkem. Ghee.
Õpetaja: Sihiväärtus, mis meil taustal tegelikult Igal tsüklil on, on see
Õpetaja: transaction type punkt Transaction Type Id. Meil on asjad, mida me esitleme niiöelda oma esitluses
Õpetaja: ja meil on asjad Mis tegelikult taustal on iga rea kohta olemas. Aga which was not to show.
Õpetaja: Siin võib olla väga palju muid andmeid, ka igasuguseid asju, Näiteks selles objektis Siin me ei taha näidata. Aga teadmiseks, teile, nad on olemas,
Õpetaja: onju? Siin on need võtmed ju
Õpetaja: selle järgi, et kui Need numbrid nagu kuskil peaks muutuma, siis ta teab, et ta peab uuesti renderdama.
Õpetaja: Nii, okei, aga nüüd on siis see et taustal on Veel ka väärtus, piisav ailable.
Õpetaja: Ja meil taaskis on öeldud. Vaata, et nüüd, see, mida kuvatakse, peab tulema selle pealt,
Õpetaja: Kui on truu, siis peaks lüliti olema
Õpetaja: sees, kui on väljas. Hetkel tundub, et kõik on sees, sest me ei ole praegu sidunud neid andmeid, mille pealt niiöelda Need Ee, Switchid niiöelda ehitatakse. Ei ole, ei ole sidunud neid veel selle väärtusega.
Õpetaja: Mm Okei,
Õpetaja: nüüd oleks küsimus. Nagu. Vaata, et oota, aga Kuidas nüüd siis seda asja teha? Et tegemist on Checkboxiga? Ta on input.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma saan seda siduda?
Õpetaja: Mäletate niukest väärtust nagu checked kui Checkt atribuut on, siis kõik on sees, kui teda pole, Nad on väljas.
Õpetaja: Teisisõnu, tal saab ka olla väärtus.
Õpetaja: Ma pean korra panema vist selle kooloni ette. Mitu True ja Falls ei tööta. Ta saab olla Kas True
Õpetaja: kõik on sees?
Õpetaja: Falls, Kõik on väljas, töötab, aga meil on nüüd vaja öelda sa nüüd kirjutamise kohta peate ka panemas ja
Õpetaja: pool on
Õpetaja: checked võrdub.
Õpetaja: Noh, ja nüüd ei ole mitte midagi jälle erinevat igal tsüklil. Me käime läbi neid objekte Igal tsüklil on meil muutuja, mille taga on üks objekt.
Õpetaja: No siis kirjutamegi siia. Tt Transaction Type
Õpetaja: punkt. No seda teab peast juba Vaila, play.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et nüüd see checkt väärtus. Kas sees või väljas tuleb
Õpetaja: internetist ja need peavad olema Maas.
Õpetaja: Saan proovida ka kohe. Vaata, kas see töötab või mitte.
Õpetaja: Kasutan seda, Tulen siia datablokki. Kus on see Location? Teen lahti. Näiteks selle. Ma ei tea raha välja.
Õpetaja: Siin on see False taustal. Muudan ära.
Õpetaja: Bimbim on lahe.
Õpetaja: Kujutage ette seda gruppi. Vaata, kes siis nagu Lõpus
Õpetaja: Aa, Dave tools on ka by the way By dave Tools Väga. Mõnus tööriist saab niimoodi mõnusalt proovida
Õpetaja: Mõte On Selge vastavad. Andmetele Voolavad andmed Child I
Õpetaja: Ja need on seotud selle checktiga.
Õpetaja: Name Id.
Õpetaja: Kõik need andmed on seotud.
Õpetaja: No päris hea
Õpetaja: okei, Ah, No see Võib olla Niukene. Aa. Nüüd on see, et on eraldi objekt, aga taaskis öeldakse, et, ee, tegelikult. See asi võiks olla kõik
Õpetaja: komponent transaction Types checkbox.
Õpetaja: Noh, aga väga hea. Võtame siis kogu selle mantrased
Õpetaja: selle diviga. Kus sees see kogu see kupatus on? On ju Võite korra Niimoodi kokku tõmmata Teeme. Sellest eraldi
Õpetaja: uue komponendi.
Õpetaja: Siit valin nii. Mai, Miks Track küsib nime.
Õpetaja: Transaction Taip. Ma piilun korra types.
Õpetaja: Tšek Boks.
Õpetaja: Siin Muidugi võiks ka niimoodi teha, et see on ainsuses ja checkbox sees. Ma ei tea, kas niimoodi üldse ongi. Vaata, õhk Midagi imelik Näeb välja, ee. Siin on lihtsalt siis transaction types. Checkbox. Lihtsalt niimoodi. Mis ta nüüd ise ära tegi?
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele? Vaata seda, et Ta võttis ee seest Transaction Type objekti ja seda kasutati meil seal.
Õpetaja: Ee, Tegelikult Location It ennast kasutatakse Ee selles koodis endas.
Õpetaja: Siin on Hästi, natukene ruumi väiksele, kui tahaks.
Õpetaja: Mm, vaadake siin. Sellest kihist vastab. Tõele. Antakse alla kaasa kogu location objekt, on, nii
Õpetaja: Aga mida me Tegelikult siin kasutame.
Õpetaja: Ei kasuta tervet Location objekti vaid väga väikest osa selles checkboxide lahenduses, mida me kasutame.
Õpetaja: Ja ehk siis, see, mis on Location I sees, onju? Transaction types. Mina pakun, et teeme niukse niukse. Tši priki. Vaata, teeme ühe propsi juurde.
Õpetaja: Võtame selle nime Transaction types, Teeme koodi Natukene ilusamaks.
Õpetaja: Ütleme no transaction types. Ta nüüd vajab tüüpi. Mis tüüpi info siin on?
Õpetaja: Strind Ta ei ole number, ta ei ole. Mis ta on? Siis on ju massive?
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd teeks niimoodi, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: see koht, kus meile antakse, et Location Ite saab kaasa võtta Transaction types. I plaan on nagu kaotada ära. See propsid. Seda ei ole vaja,
Õpetaja: aga teeme niimoodi. Step by step, et kõik jääks tööle,
Õpetaja: et lähme nüüd tagasi sinna. Location Forum I, kus kutsutakse välja Ee Transaction Type Checkbox.
Õpetaja: Nii siin öeldakse. Vaata, et. Hei, anna Location Ile kaasa. Location on nii?
Õpetaja: Ütleme siin, et hoopis Control take.
Õpetaja: Anname hoopis kaasa transaction. Types. Ile
Õpetaja: mitte location i vaid location I seest oleva
Õpetaja: Transaction types It. Ehk me anname tegelikult sinna sellesse komponenti kaasa. Ainult selle, mida tal tegelikult on. Vaja
Õpetaja: Saate mõttest aru,
Õpetaja: meil ei ole mõtet Tervet Location It sinna komponenti kaasa anda, sest ta ei kasuta absoluutselt ühtegi teist. Osa sellest Location Ist. Tal ei ole vaja City Id D. Tal ei ole vaja location Name. Tal ei ole vaja mitte midagi, muud. Transaction Type Checkboxil on ainult vaja. Lihtsalt massiivi Transaction types. See on tegelikult, mida ta tegelt vajab.
Õpetaja: Kui praegu vaadata seda vaadet, siis ee. Ilmselt lähevad asjad tuksi.
Õpetaja: Üldse on puudu. Vaata Sellepärast, et ee. Arris on hetkel praegult. Niiöelda on endiselt kasutuses. Vaata, see location.
Õpetaja: No siia ei tule enam midagi.
Õpetaja: Selle võib ära kustutada,
Õpetaja: Nüüd on siis see koht. Siin On ju, et. Oota, Aga me tegime Four tsüklit Location objekti pealt, aga seda pole enam.
Õpetaja: Me kustutame ära, aga on olemas Transaction types, on nii
Õpetaja: Transaction types tuleb alles selle pealt. Joonistame oma lahenduses
Õpetaja: Tuli tuli seda mõtet Me hakkame jaavas ka jälgima. Tegelikult
Õpetaja: me tegelikult, ee. Peaksime Andma. Niiöelda. Kas siis meetodile või komponendile nüüd on Niukene asi tehtud niiöelda, et meil ei ole mõtet, nagu anda sinna palju rohkem informatsiooni
Õpetaja: kui vaja.
Õpetaja: See mõttekoht mille anda Näiteks kogu objekt, on see, et kui seal oleks näiteks ühte välja veel kuskil lahenduses. Kasutame Siis juba võiks öelda. Vaata, et anname siis kogu objekti ja siis sealt alt saab võtta ainult need osad tema, mis tema tahab?
Õpetaja: Kuigi ka, siis on vaja variant. Vaata seda, et. Okei, Meil on mingisugune objekt, kus on mingi kuuskümmend välja all On ainult vaja kolme asja.
Õpetaja: No aga siis saab teha niimoodi selle komponendi, et mina, võtan ee, kolm erinevat infokildu sisse
Õpetaja: ja nüüd sealt, Kus me välja kutsume, siis me annamegi ainult kolm väikest osa kaasa.
Õpetaja: Aga kui on juba nagu see, et vaata, et ei seal all on viite asja vaja. Me nagu ei tahaks teha niimoodi, et anname viis erinevat tükki kaasa, et sa nagu niuke mõistuse piires ee. Peab jälgima, et millal me. Nagu hakkaksime andma? Ee, erinevalt. Mis on selle mõte?
Õpetaja: Vaadake, kui me ütleme seda, et me anname siia alla kaasa Location objekti. Kus sees on? Transaction types?
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd ja programmeerime kõik siit niimoodi. Location I seest, Võta transaction types ja sellega tee voortsükleid Kui meil on selline niiöelda lahendus siin Childis, siis ta ongi seotud sellise mudeliga, et edaspidi, kui näiteks mingis teises kohas, me tahame ka kasutada seda sama komponenti uuesti.
Õpetaja: Tahame seda sama komponenti uuesti kasutada. Kuskil
Õpetaja: siis on niimoodi. Et hetkel ta eeldabki seda, et sa annad mulle Objekti ja Transaction types I. Aga võibolla siin teises kohas.
Õpetaja: Meil infona ja objektina ja mudelina ongi ainult Transaction Times. Neid teisi asju pole, Siis me ei hakka tehislikult tekitama mingisugust asja. Et Oota, teeme nüüd kuidagi taustal Location objekti ja siin sees on transaction types, saate aru Ta Ta ootab.
Õpetaja: Meil on programmeeritud see, kui meil on tehtud selle väga väikse osa peale see info, siis ta on üli lihtsalt taaskasutatav Igal pool.
Õpetaja: Ainuke asi, mis ta tahab, on see, et anna mulle transaction types, Kus on sees Massiivi? Sees on transaction type Id Ee Transaction Type Name. Ja ma töötan.
Õpetaja: Mingid Location ist ei ole haisugi.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi saame seda asja päris kindlalt taaskasutada kuskil uuesti
Õpetaja: sest et see Ei ole nagu laiskusest või mugavusest tekitatud nagu niukest.
Õpetaja: Ee, asja, et me anname siia, kuna lihtsalt see koht, kus me ühe korra kasutasime, Meil Oli lihtne Location Objek kaasa anda. Ei, ei, anname ainult selle osa, mis on vaja,
Õpetaja: sest nüüd see asi ei ole kuidagi seotud kunagi objektiga, vaid alati. Ainult Transaction Type types. Massive objektiga.
Õpetaja: Nii on siin kohal. Küsimusi ei ole. Ee, tundub, et selle asja saime ka Tehtud, aga al alles poolenisti.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaatame korra, kui mina vaatan praegu siit selle Dev toolsiga. Näiteks Ee, Vaatan Location Views meie Location Objekti.
Õpetaja: Kui mina kirjutan siia Tallinn, Kui mina panen siia, asukohanimeks. A, Kui ma panen siia sada,
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen koordinaadid. Ee, viiskümmend koma tühik. Ee, mina ei tea. Kuuskümmend,
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen, panen lihtsalt ee, Raha sisse. Panen sisse.
Õpetaja: Kui ma nüüd korra vaatan. Nagu et mis toimub. Location I data Selles. Data blokis olevad Location objektiga. Siis ma näen, et City on kaks location Name on A Number of on tuhat on viiskümmend longitud. On kuuskümmend. So far so good.
Õpetaja: Kui ma nüüd tulen nüüd selle transaction types massiivi juurde, Ja Vaatan, raha sisse
Õpetaja: kandja Tahaks oodata, et siis on true, Aga ta on Force
Õpetaja: Praegult Me ei ole kuidagi progenud seda asja ära, et kui All Childis midagi toimub?
Õpetaja: Siis see info jõuaks üles ja tagasi teiste asjadega. Oleme teinud seda ja ja mitte. On ju nii?
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: Davai. Ee, proovime siis seda asja ära teha, aga ma kujutan ette ära, et siin nüüd on nüüd väikene probleem.
Õpetaja: Okei, et kaksteist.
Õpetaja: Siin on nüüd väikene probleem, Vaadake, me ei tohi Childis kunagi Ee, muuta seda objekti, mis meile sisse voolab.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on niimoodi, et meil on tegelikult vaja siis Kind of Saata informatsioon, et Kuule, ole
Õpetaja: ole hunnupall. Sul on siin kolm objekti
Õpetaja: ühel nendest, kui ma hoidan tik ja on Event Ühel nendest. Ja mitte nagu suvaliselt, vaid konkreetsel
Õpetaja: transaction type ja ideal.
Õpetaja: Muuda ära Isabele väärtuseks.
Õpetaja: Selline, nagu mina kaasa annan. Kas saate mõttest aru,
Õpetaja: Me peame üle ülevalt poolt peavad andmed tagasi Flowma meile muudetud väärtusega. Ehk. Siis kui mina. Praegult ju vajutasin selle taustal kõik nad on False Id. Mina praegu vajutan sisse. Välja.
Õpetaja: Siis siin visuaalis.
Õpetaja: See interaktiivne element muutub, aga taustal andmed ei muutu alla. Ikka on siiamaani.
Õpetaja: Ma Võin Mida iganes teha siin, praegu, Daielda Aga siia alla siia. Transaction Type Checkbox I
Õpetaja: siin. Kui see raha sisse kogu aeg Lihtsalt False
Õpetaja: Tee, mis tahad. Pane sisse, mine minema, tule siia, Vaata,
Õpetaja: paned sisse. No nüüd ta peakski muutuma.
Õpetaja: Ta on kogu aeg False. Miks sellepärast, et ülevalt need andmed voolasid ühe korra siia sisse
Õpetaja: Ja see interaktiivne element ei ole kuidagi seotud. Meil pole siin mingit veemudelit näiteks mis Seoks neid kahte asja, Kui tahaks.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et tuleb teha mitt nii nagu keegi välja pakkus
Õpetaja: otsime, siis selle koha ülesse. Kus see infot on.
Õpetaja: Alustame niimoodi korra. Vaadake lihtsalt, ma teen korra. Teeme lihtsa alertiga jälle, et kas ma saan selle asja tööle Panen Mingi Alert test.
Õpetaja: Panen siia alert ja kirjutan siia lihtsalt praegu, et toimus muuda toimus. Toimus muudatus või mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: nüüd, kuidas seda, input I käima siin on natukene. Nüüd. Ee. Selle minu meelest vist on see Change. Ma proovin kohe ära. Lihtsalt Change peaks olema
Õpetaja: Ad Change Käivita alert Est.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, et kas ta idee järgi hakkab reageerima. Vahet pole, millest ma vajutan. Toimus muudatus, Toimus muudatus,
Õpetaja: Toimus Muudatus on nii Okei,
Õpetaja: ee, võibolla järgmine samm võiks olla see, et ta ütleb, et toimus muudatus. Aga millises objektis?
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et Kas vastab tõele see meetod
Õpetaja: Mis mul siin praegu on, toimus muudatus. Tema on universaalne. Vahet pole, millist nuppu mina käivitan, käivitub koguaeg üks ja Seesama. Test,
Õpetaja: aga see on küsimus, aga kus siis? Toimus muudatus?
Õpetaja: Nii, okei, mõtleme seda asja Aga mis siis kui mina teen niimoodi? See sama alert test võiks öelda. Mulle
Õpetaja: Transaction Type Id Väärtuse Mida ma siis siin Alerdis esialgu lihtsalt kuvan.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis ma panen praegu siia Lr testi et kui See Change Event käivitab Allr testi. Esialgu ma panen lihtsalt mingi suvalise numbrilise väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Klikin toimus muudatus.
Õpetaja: Toimus muudatus toimus muudatus,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd see Trikk ongi selles. Vaata, et mina siin, nagu selles meetodis. Ei tea, et milline dünaamiline element niiöelda selle meetodi käivitus.
Õpetaja: Aga kas te mäletate seda sama informatsiooni,
Õpetaja: mida ma korraks lihtsalt panin siia niimoodi. No paneme nüüd seekord niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ma Panin korra siia juurde lihtsalt kuvama, et iga Selle Switch I taga on. Id on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, et kui mina nüüd vajutan mingit klikki,
Õpetaja: Noh, siis kui mina saan juba kuvada seda väärtust, siis see väärtus on mul olemas.
Õpetaja: Ehk vajutamise hetkel on ikkagi teada.
Õpetaja: Siis mina saangi öelda siit selles Alar testis, et Kuule, aga ole
Õpetaja: tšillipilli. Kui sa käivitad alert testi, võta siis praegult selle objekti. Transaction type Id ja Kuva. Seda teeme. Refresh
Õpetaja: toimus Muudatus, üks toimus, muudatus. Kolm toimus, muudatus.
Õpetaja: Kaks toimus muudatus. Kaks toimus muudatus. Kaks töötab.
Õpetaja: Mida te veel võiks nüüd muidugi öelda? Vaata on See, et endiselt see on visuaalne pool. Mina ei tea, kas ta on ee sisse lülitatud või välja lülitatud vastata.
Õpetaja: Mm, siis kui tore Oleks mul see, et. Ee. Mul oleks siin veel üks meetodis niiöelda muutuja checked value
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: ja jällegi, ee, siis kui tore oleks, lihtsalt, Kui no teeme nagu Step by Step Esialgu, ma panen lihtsalt selle true
Õpetaja: ta, et iga kord kui käivitad,
Õpetaja: kui tu toimub Change event Selles Switchboxis,
Õpetaja: Siis läheb Alert Transaction Type Id. Esialgu lihtsalt vaikimise väärtus True.
Õpetaja: Ee, oota. Pean Muutma ka. Nagu et, ee, siin, seda et Alertis oleks midagi näha.
Õpetaja: Väärtus pool on mis iganes on checkt value väärtus.
Õpetaja: Ehk praegu kui ma vajutan, toimus muudatus. Üks väärtus true toimus, Muudatus. Üks väärtus true. Aga kontseptsioonina võiks töötada. On ju
Õpetaja: ehk siis nüüd see koht, Kus siis see Ad Change triggerdab Event i Alert test.
Õpetaja: Ta annab dünaamiliselt selle väärtuse niiöelda, mis käivitus.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on mul vaja selle konkreetse checkboxi checkt väärtust ja mina annan siin väärtuse Aga Siin
Õpetaja: nüüd tuleb sama asi, mis me oleme varem teinud. Kui mina. Kui see Change käivitub, siis see on Event.
Õpetaja: Mina kirjutan nüüd Siia, Vent Dollari märgiga. Target, mis mind siin huvitab.
Õpetaja: No mis mind huvitab siin. Mind huvitab see checkt väärtus.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen, et anna mulle See väärtus, mis on seal punkt
Õpetaja: coping kasus alles ikkagi nii, siis nüüd. Me saame näha, et kui ma teen refresh I,
Õpetaja: et ma Näen, kus kohas see meetod käivitub, Et mis on transaction Type diesel?
Õpetaja: Ja mis on uus väärtus True, Ma ütlen, Okei, no siis ta Pildil kuvab ka. Keeran selle välja.
Õpetaja: Töötab nüüd. Minul on olemas tegelikult kaks infokildu.
Õpetaja: Minul on olemas Kaks infokildu, mille põhjal mina saaks nüüd põhimõtteliselt Barentile öelda. Vaata, et Kuule,
Õpetaja: oleme tšillipilli. Sina saadad mulle alla Transaction types massive
Õpetaja: aga ole hea, Mine nüüd otsi ülesse Id üks, Ja
Õpetaja: pane tema niiöelda väärtus selleks, mis mina sulle ütlen.
Õpetaja: True või False Saate aru, mis see plaan on
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et andmed voolavad ülevalt alla
Õpetaja: Ainukene moodus. Kuidas mina saan süngis hoida. Seda visuaalset Html, elementi ja andmeid taustal on see, et andmed peavad ka muutuma, aga sa Automaagiliselt ise. Kuidagi ei toimu.
Õpetaja: Ma pean selle ära lihtsalt programmeerima.
Õpetaja: Aga siin ongi nagu see, et kahjuks on nüüd juba vaata kahte infokildu Vanasti saatsime kogu aeg ühe asja. City Id
Õpetaja: või input kastist. Nagu väärtus. Vaata mustamäe prismaadi. Ja Aga nüüd on nagu see, et, Oot, Oot, aga natukene rohkem on vaja.
Õpetaja: Ma demonstreerisin seda, et idee järgi on võimalik mitu pakki saata ka teele. Ütlesin ka et linnule, lihtsalt Joonistad teed mitu pakiga? Aga See ei ole tava.
Õpetaja: Kui mina tahan midagi saata nagu ülesse, poole
Õpetaja: siis ja on rohkem infot, kui ee, Rohkem seal on nagu rohkem infot kui ee. Niiöelda kui üks infokilg, siis üks lahendus on see, et ma lihtsalt teen ühe uue objekti
Õpetaja: uue objekti, Sest et objekti sisse. Ma võin nii palju väljasid kirjutada, kui ma ise tahan ja panna mistahes väärtuse,
Õpetaja: aga ma saadan ühe Paki nii. Nüüd on siis nagu kaasa tegemise koht.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kus Maal teie olete?
Õpetaja: Teil Kas teil on midagi? Tegelikult, tulge lihtsalt kõik Järgi Teeme lihtsamalt veits.
Õpetaja: Või tahate programmeerida? Seda nullist tegi keegi kaasa.
Õpetaja: Ei teinud, ei pidanud. Tegema Teeme uuesti. Harjutame Aa, Ma pakun, et teil üldse pole, Ei ole. Nii
Õpetaja: On tühi
Õpetaja: Kehvad seisud on, Aga teeme, niimoodi et teeme ka tühjaks
Õpetaja: ja kogu Noh, seda ridadel polegi seda. Ad Change, onju? Kustutan selle ära.
Õpetaja: Nii, Kas nüüd oleme ühel joonel Morless?
Õpetaja: Nii siis meie teeme korraks ühe uue. Niiöelda, Ee, meetodi
Õpetaja: Paneme selle meetodi nimeks. Ee, ja see on jälle Potato Potato, onju? Mis See nimi võiks olla?
Õpetaja: Mina Pakuks niimoodi
Õpetaja: Event.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: tahaks öelda. Transaction Type Checkbox.
Õpetaja: Mis See komponendi nimi on? Niiöelda? Okei, teeme niimoodi. Koppige see siit, Vaata, et natukene vähem kirjutada ja mitte Vent
Õpetaja: Transaction Types checkbox.
Õpetaja: Selle update,
Õpetaja: Sest et ta peab kirjeldama sündmust, Mis toimub siin all on ju
Õpetaja: kui me pärast toime Event transaction type checkbox
Õpetaja: Input Change, Change, Checked
Õpetaja: checked.
Õpetaja: Sest et see on Switch. Vaata, muidugi, meil. Aga ta on checkbox.
Õpetaja: Kui me juba nimi on Checkbox, siis me Peame põhimõtteliselt ütleme. See kindel Lihtsalt ütleb, et transaction type checkboxiga midagi. Check,
Õpetaja: Aga tšekk muidugi justkui viitaks, et ta lülitati sisse. Vaata Ta Ka enda ei peegelda niukest neutraalsust sisse või välja.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: oleme update.
Õpetaja: Switch. Switch sütš.
Õpetaja: No see viimane oli. Las Jääb nii, Ma Arvan, Kuluta. Aega Ta ütleb, et auto. Ma ei viitsi sellele mõelda.
Õpetaja: Ee, control shift enter.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ongi, et seda, me ee, kavatseme käivitada Ja Siin on kahte infopildi vaja.
Õpetaja: Siin on vaja transaction Type Id D, mida saab siit kopida
Õpetaja: ja siia teine muuta võib olla Checked
Õpetaja: väga ei meeldi, aga ma ei viitsi. Ee, siin kaua saagida.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis mida see Event peab tegema?
Õpetaja: Noh, siin öeldakse on ju, et Event i event. Iga peab seda update tegema. Aga nüüd on minu mõte on see. Vaata, et, ee,
Õpetaja: aa, Teeme ühe uue kohaliku muutuja.
Õpetaja: Paneme update checkbox ja see on objekt. Kuidas saab objekti kõige lihtsamal viisil? Teha?
Õpetaja: Jah, uus objekt tekib kohe
Õpetaja: nüüd see siia. Oleks vaja Mingisuguseid. Ee, niiöelda parameetreid. Ehk siis või nagu muutuja nimesid.
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame, mis meil siin sisse tuleb, siis ma arvan, et võiks nagu kasutada neid kahte, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ütleme, et selles objektis on Niukene väline nagu Transaction Taipidi.
Õpetaja: Kool on tema Väärtus Tuleb Kust kohast?
Õpetaja: No see Sama Transaction Type I Teamsi ja meetodisse Sisse tuleb ja teine väli on.
Õpetaja: Ja tema väärtus on see, mis sisse tuleb. Vaadake neid värve Nüüd need on siin objekti muutujad, kropsid
Õpetaja: ja need on väärtused. Need on väärtused, mis tulevad sisse.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siis tuleb see sama meetod põhimõtteliselt Aa, okei, See objekt on olemas, aga midagi sa sellega ei tee, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ja plaan ongi. Lihtsalt see objekt saata.
Õpetaja: See sama objekt, Kus on niuksed väärtused?
Õpetaja: Siis kuidas me seda miitimist teeme?
Õpetaja: Dispunt, emit, soolad.
Õpetaja: See peab tulema, Url.
Õpetaja: Noh, pakkuge, mis hurd võiks olla.
Õpetaja: No, Kui me ühe korra oleme selle ära mõelnud. Mis see meetod teeb? See meetod ütleb, mis on meetodi nimi Mida teeb meetod?
Õpetaja: Mitte Event Transaction Type Checkbox. Update, et no mis võiks olla siis selle Event I nimi?
Õpetaja: Tere, ma võtan korra see pikk. No sõna ei, saaks öelda, aga sõnad.
Õpetaja: Aga ma copy based Isin selle meetodi nimest. Aga loomulikult peab nüüd selle tegema. Niimoodi. Korda. Transaction types
Õpetaja: checkbox.
Õpetaja: Update ära Nagu Superhappy sellega grammivõõral. Nagu läheks kogu see asi pikaks.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ei näe nagu ka midagi lühemalt praegult midagi ei saaks olla Chat Iga saaks arutada ja mõelda seda, kui aega oleks. Aga ei soovi.
Õpetaja: Kui see nüüd on, siis see Event, mis läheb nüüd järgmisena peaks tulema, siis mis asi?
Õpetaja: Pakikene, mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Ee, kirjuta Vend Event on see, kui sa kohe viskad eelmiselt ee eelmiselt niiöelda ee, vendilt tulnud pakikest edasi
Õpetaja: siin. Kui ma küsiks üldse Event Nagu ma küsin, et siin ma ei näe ühtegi selle. See on meetodi blokk, mis Ei, tee oma välisest elus tööd ega mütsi. Vastab tõele,
Õpetaja: et tema ei tea midagi mingisugust eventist.
Õpetaja: Väga objekti oleks vaja.
Õpetaja: On väga Hea data objekti vaja. No mis meil on? See data objekt.
Õpetaja: Update. Checkbox, Kas vastab tõele et Siin tekib Üks uus objekt on.
Õpetaja: Kas Vastab tõele, et seal on niuksed välja. Transaction Type Id ja Checkt on.
Õpetaja: Millega on see objekt praegu seotud muutujaga Update checkbox, on nii?
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma nüüd saan siin viidata sellele objektile?
Õpetaja: Noh, keerutab
Õpetaja: Update checkbox. Kõik muutus Sai valgeks.
Õpetaja: Oih, ennem oli siin see joon all, Vaata, et keegi kunagi ei kasuta.
Õpetaja: Kui me tahaks teha seda natukene lühemaks, et siin on kaine Nagu see, et see on kaine nagu return,
Õpetaja: Sa lood muutuja nime.
Õpetaja: Sa kasutad seda ainult ühe, korra mitte mitu korda. Ja juba järgmisel real, kus põhimõtteliselt kogu meetod saab oma loogilise Lõpu. Siin oleks see ka variant niimoodi teha anonüümseks, et siit lihtsalt paned kohe selle objekti
Õpetaja: Saate aru mõtest,
Õpetaja: et kas sul on seda muutujat vaja, aga ma ei teeks seda. Ma teeks täpselt niimoodi nagu siin.
Õpetaja: Miks sa seda Nüüd on meil mingisugune fucking nimi. Update ja Checkbox. Sest et me peame mõtlema sellele, et kui see objekt nüüd läheb ülesse poole põp teele,
Õpetaja: sest lõpuks ee, peab käivituma mingisugune meetod,
Õpetaja: mis hakkab käima läbi seda olemasolevat Ee, massiivi ja siis
Õpetaja: sissetulnud objekti pealt. Ta peab võtma need andmed Transaction type Id ja Checkt ja Ta peab põhimõtteliselt nende andmetega käima. Nüüd kogu selle massiivi seal kenasti läbi
Õpetaja: leidma oma vastme vaste et kus on see Id sama
Õpetaja: ja muutma väärtuse ära. Aga see tähendab, seda, et meil hakkab olema mingisugune meetod,
Õpetaja: mis võtab sisse mingisuguse objekti selle sama objekti ja seal on Meil vaja parameetri nime. Mis võiks olla seal pärast parameetri nimi,
Õpetaja: kui me siin kutsume seda objekti.
Õpetaja: Jah, pomm, et kui me teeksime seda Anonüümselt.
Õpetaja: Näiteks niimoodi. Vaata, et muutujat ta ei ole. Et Panen kohe selle objekti loomise siia, Sest et nii saab ka teha, vaata pole Mingit probleemi siis on nagu seal, et me mõtleme välja, mi? Me peame niikuinii mõtlema mingi parameetri nime
Õpetaja: ja siis nagu on ka enda See, et mis iganes sa seal mõtled, see kuskile ei viita. Kui meil on vähemalt tehtud niimoodi, et meil on see muutuja ja on See kasutatud siis, kui keegi loeks seda koodi. Tal tekiks. Küsimus, et mis asi see on? Ta võiks ainult üle projekti seda otsida, kui ta tahaks. Kas seda muutuja nime kuskil ei kasutada?
Õpetaja: Satuks siia muidugi. Ega ta jõuaks otsapidi. Niikuinii. Vaata, Ta ju näeb, et sellest tuleb Mingi event.
Õpetaja: Ahah, Okei. Ja tulevad mingid andmed ja käivitus. See meetmed ega seda on kõike võimalik Trace, ida rahulikult niiöelda välja ja otsapidi jõuaks ikkagi siia. Aga lihtsalt, et ka nagu koodilugeja, saaks paremini aru, kui ta tuleb siia lõpuks ja loeb.
Õpetaja: Aa, siin On Checkboxid. Aa, kui toimub siin Niiöelda
Õpetaja: Ee, okei. Väljakutsumist ei ole Praegu hetkel onju, et kui toimub, käivitatakse see meetod,
Õpetaja: pannakse kokku, see informatsioon, mis saadakse Dünaamilisest input ist saadetakse see eraldi objektina. Kaks väärtust
Õpetaja: saadakse ülesse. Selle nimi on Ka Update Checkpox tal kõik jookseks pilt kokku, nagu Okei, Saan aru,
Õpetaja: ta saaks muidugi hea koodilugeja ja kogenud arendaja saaks ka loomulikult sellest aru aga ka, talle läheks grammi võrra rohkem aega
Õpetaja: et viia nagu pilt kokku, et. Oot, oot, kuidas Kuidas siin see arendaja selle asja nagu kokku programmeeris.
Õpetaja: No ee, kui aega on, siis võiksime Võibolla küsida Codreview D. Nii öelda. Näiteks Cloudilt. Kuule,
Õpetaja: mis sa arvad sellest? Ilmselt ta pakuks ka võibolla mingit oma varianti aga ma ütlen Ka sellega, on nii? Ja nii. Vaata, võib täna tegelikult pakkuda tõesti mingit elegantsemat aa lahendust. Selles mõttes, et ta kirjaviis on lühikene, lihtne Ja ma ei tea, mida iganes,
Õpetaja: aga seal ongi küsimus. See, et teie, kui algajad, kui hästi te saate sellest elegantsest koolist aru kuna, Sinna tekib mingisugust koledat abstraktsiooni,
Õpetaja: Et, Ee, ise pead nagu veits nagu oma protsessorit. Nagu vaevama rohkem.
Õpetaja: Ja täna teil lihtsalt ei ole veel seda kogemust.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma ise võiksin ka täiesti vabalt niukeste asjadega, et saada aru.
Õpetaja: Ee, keegi mind ei taha keegi Ei, kutsu no nüüd Läheme siis, sinna, et kui inputis toimub Change, keegi muudab neid.
Õpetaja: Tahamegi seda kahte infokildu öelda. Ei, mis on see väärtus.
Õpetaja: Nii, tuleme siia Input I.
Õpetaja: Kirjutame at Change.
Õpetaja: Ütleme Change I peale. Käivitub meetod transaction typed checkbox, Update meetod.
Õpetaja: Väga Ikkagi ei meeldi see nimi, aga mida Sa teed sulgudesse. Tema ootab kahte sisendit. Nüüd Aa, jootale. Miks,
Õpetaja: mis Vaatab? Ju.
Õpetaja: Huvitav Control B. No parameeters.
Õpetaja: Miks ta arvab, et sellel Meetodil ei ole parameetreid, kui tegelikult on.
Õpetaja: Mina ei tea, See on ka intellige
Õpetaja: esimesena väärtusena. Me tahame Transaction Type Id D Siin fortsüklis Käime läbi kõiki asju. Massiivis. Me ei muutu. Transaction Type Key on Transaction Type Id No seda Keyd. Me tegelikult soovimegi,
Õpetaja: et paneme siia Esimeseks
Õpetaja: ja teise parameetrina läheb sisse. Siis
Õpetaja: checkt. Väärtus Vot seda. Nüüd Saame siin selle. Event. Iga Event
Õpetaja: punkt target. Teeme selle veits kitsamaks. Event punkt. Target punkt. Anna mulle check väärtus.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma lihtsalt korra mulle endale Nagu mingi paranoia. Vaata, et kas siis emit läheb või ei lähe,
Õpetaja: siis ma korra. Lihtsalt teen selle väikse Alerdi
Õpetaja: alert ja panen selle sama. Update checkboxi kui ee objekti objekti ta ei oska Kuvada alertis. Ma Ütlen korra. Jason. Stringify. Palun tee see. Update Checkbox. Lihtsalt, ee, niiöelda objekte. String iks.
Õpetaja: Ma korra vaatan nagu et kas Seal Ert tuleb või ei tule, Sest et ee. Mind paneb muretsema seda, et ta ei tunne seda meetodit kuidagi hästi. Ära. Mulle tundub, et läheb objekt. Näete
Õpetaja: Transaction Type Id. Üks ja checkt väärtus true maksega ka.
Õpetaja: Lülite midagi välja ka? Noh, töötab, onju Selline objekt peab minema parentile. Kas te saate aru? Me tahtsime. Meil oli vaja seda fookus fookust selleks teha, et, ee, me tahame saata
Õpetaja: ülesse poole mingisuguseid andmeid
Õpetaja: ja me tahame seekord lihtsalt saata natukene rohkem kui üks. Meie valikus oli, et läheb kaks pakki teele.
Õpetaja: Aa, see oli üks valik Ja oleks saanud selle ära progeda.
Õpetaja: Aga me pigem eelistame ikkagi standard lähenemist, et üks Event ja üks pakk,
Õpetaja: aga selle jaoks me pidime tegema ühe uue objekti.
Õpetaja: See on väga hea näide ka. Vaata, et teil on kogu aeg see vabadus,
Õpetaja: et te saate mistahes hetkel teha Mistahes objekte mistahes sisuga Frontis, nii nagu vaja.
Õpetaja: Saate sinna panna mingit infot.
Õpetaja: Nii, okei,
Õpetaja: ma kustutan selle osa siit ära, et on see Label I juures. Need väärtused. Me juba õppisime selle ära, et siin on tegelikult taustal väärtused.
Õpetaja: No nüüd ei ole muud midagi kui jälle See sama rada. Vaata, et ee, seda pakikest tuleb nüüd toimetada. Läbi Location Formi Location Views sa välja.
Õpetaja: Aa, aa. Mis siis võiks teha
Õpetaja: Siin selles Child komponent is võiks ära määrata, et. Ee, see meetod.
Õpetaja: Ee emit Ib Midagi Vajadusel ehk siia, eksport Default I tulla ja Kirjutada Mits kool on panna kandilised sulud
Õpetaja: ja siis tulla kopida, See
Õpetaja: Aa, et copida see Event I nimi koos nende jutumärkidega, et
Õpetaja: see Asi siin võib ju miittida niukest asja. Meil on siis progeda Lihtsam. Seda järgmist korrust
Õpetaja: on lihtsam. Aa, seda teha
Õpetaja: võiks juba tegelikult Ee, Noh, selle asja siin uuesti. Kui kuigi just kopisime ühe korra veel. Copile,
Õpetaja: Lähme nüüd. Location Forum I korruse ülesse otsime. Tema Ei, mitsi Ülesse on siin. Need emitsid
Õpetaja: Paneme koma koma Juba siin eelmisest korrast on ja paneme ühe vendi juurde,
Õpetaja: sest et nüüd on progeda võimalik siin ka niimoodi, et ta teab selle kohta kõike.
Õpetaja: Nüüd meie vaatame, kus kohas Transaction types Checkbox. Niiöelda kutsutakse välja alla lähevad andmed,
Õpetaja: siia Soovime samamoodi, et. Kuule, aga alt tuleb Event.
Õpetaja: Paneme siia ät märgi, kui tuleb alt. Event event transaction, Typ checkbox updated põmm.
Õpetaja: Noh, me Oleme nüüd selle parent I juures. Info vai? Mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Võrdusmärk, mis me tahame teha?
Õpetaja: Tahame edasi miittida seda lihtsalt onju ja Miit pool on jutumärgid.
Õpetaja: Tänu sellele, et sinna mütsi sai. Ära topitud See uus asi.
Õpetaja: Siis leiame ülesse et see vend Transaction Type Checkbox update on siin niimoodi. Ee, ke kenasti valitav.
Õpetaja: Nüüd et ära ei unusta, mida siin peab tegema Me ei, mitte ainult ülesse poole, Event I vaid ka,
Õpetaja: mis? Tahame veel teele panna.
Õpetaja: Tuvi ka.
Õpetaja: No paki. Tahame teile ka panna, On ju? Tal on ju kaks osa. Event Il ee, vabandust. On, ee põhimõtteliselt mingi event name. Ja siis nagu pakikene
Õpetaja: dollari. Märk Ja Event annab meile. Selle.
Õpetaja: Taanded on paigast veitsa Ära I Love optimising.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on juba niimoodi, et see asi nagu nii pikaks veninud, et ta paneb päris mitmele reale, aga vahet pole, Las olla. No selle ma võibolla korraks isegi tõmbaks tagasi. Vaata, et, ee, et nagu ma ei tahaks, et on see reavahetus
Õpetaja: ja ma Ei taha, et see viimane asi on kuskil siin, et Olgu, tema. Ta läheb üle selle esimese halli joone, nagu kellel on nagu mingi Kuubiku kujuline monitor. Tänapäeval
Õpetaja: Kõigil on White Screen Id Kuskilt Tegelikult saab seda ilmselt
Õpetaja: Võibolla keegi, kes viitsib. Ee, koheselt. Võin varsti läbi ka Keegi, kes viitsib Ee, kodus proovida. Ja kord, kui ma teeks, Ma panen korra ära. Vaata selle, et ma ei, soovi et see asi Kaotsi läheb. Aga ma näitan mõtte ära. Keegi, kes viitsib mässata Niiöelda võiks uurida sellise asja,
Õpetaja: et kui siin selles location formis panna I Love Optimising Ilo.
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab teha niimoodi, et ta ei reageeriks selle tobeda kriipsu peale, vaid siis, Noh, ma ei tea, miinimum nagu järgmise Peale kuskilt seadistustest saab ilmselt. Ma pole varem kunagi näinud. See tuli nagu mingi natuke aega tagasi, et üldse näitab kahte joont, vanasti näitas Ainult ühte joont. Ta nii oli,
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd ta näitab kahte joont. Ja nagu ma ei tea, ma eeldan, et siin ongi nagu mingi Setting, et White Screen või mitte,
Õpetaja: See on nagu tobe. Nagu, mis asja? Mingi ma ei tea,
Õpetaja: Mul oli kaheteist. Aastasena oli Niukene kondiline Monitar,
Õpetaja: need ajad on veits möödas. Me olime vist panust veidi juurde visanud.
Õpetaja: Keegi, kes tahab proovida settingutes ja Cloud Code iga või kes iganes, nagu aitab tal nagu leida settingud, millega saab seda ära muuta, siis Võib teistega pärast seda jagada,
Õpetaja: aga lähme meie edasi ee, meie Pärand sai selle info kätte.
Õpetaja: Läheme siis. Ee, nüüd Location view sse.
Õpetaja: Siit võib ka tegelikult, enne kui läheme, vaata, kopime selle Event I
Õpetaja: Aa, tegelikult ei ole vaja. Siin ei ole vaja, Ee, Sest et, ee. Siin ei ole niukest asja nagu mits siin ei toimu või Mitte Location View St. Otsime ülesse, et. Kus kohas on Location Form,
Õpetaja: See on siin, tuleme. Paneme siit entri. Vajutan ätt I
Õpetaja: ja Näe, Nüüd Location Form informeerib meid, et Niukene Event nagu toimuda Location Forum is.
Õpetaja: Me paneme võrdusmärgi, et hakkaks toimuma mingi tegevus.
Õpetaja: See tegevus on nüüd piisavalt keeruline, et siin Real me seda asja ära ei tee, vaid meil on vaja teha ühte meetodit.
Õpetaja: Noh, seal on Action Id, Palju Mingi tsüklid ja võrdlemised ja vaatamised. Ja muutmised on ju? See tähendab seda, et tuleb eraldi meetod.
Õpetaja: No scroll Ime siis ülesse teeme uue meetodi ja võtame mingi nime välja sellele asjale.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui me ennem oleme viidanud siin näiteks niiöelda ee, ja midagi taolist,
Õpetaja: siis võiks Võibolla öelda update Location Transaction types või
Õpetaja: midagi taolist. Ma ei tea, veel, mõtleme.
Õpetaja: Jah, Ma ei oska midagi praegu muud välja mõelda. Update Location Transaction types
Õpetaja: Clean Cloud. Lihtsalt nagu saadakse. Vaata, et võimalikult lühikesel well Clean code. Ee, sa ei saa mulle praegu midagi, teha. Sa Oled kõigest raamat
Õpetaja: update Location Transaction types is available value.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et, ee, seda võiks võibolla kuidagi hägusamaks teha, aga ma lihtsalt praegu ei Viitsi sellega mõelda ka.
Õpetaja: Las ta siis praegu kirjeldab otse. Ma ütlen ka, et Clean Code on nagu väga tore. Ta soovitab igal pool, Nagu väga häid näpunäitajaid. Aga need näpunäited on nagu väga väikestes Nagu skoopides, vaata onju, et olen tee nii. Ja Dna on ju aga Kahjuks. Vaata, meil on vastu rääkimas. Vaata koodi Loetavus minu jaoks. East A King. Sellest ma lähtun
Õpetaja: nüüd, mis meil on vaja teha, Meil on vaja käia, siis four tsükliga. Nüüd läbi need transaction Type Id
Õpetaja: ja siis vaadata seda, et kus Aa by the way nüüd, on See, et meil on meetod olemas, mis? Me otsustasime, et meil on see objekti nimi siin.
Õpetaja: Mingi update Checkbox oli nii
Õpetaja: siia. Siis teeme Niimoodi, et kui nüüd Eventsle käivitab, siis siin on mingi sildikene. Kuhu see pagike kukub?
Õpetaja: Update Ee, karmaat. Mis see oli Update?
Õpetaja: Checkbox Update Checkbox. Lihtsalt update checkbox.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ei tea. Javascripti luupimisi mapimisi ja nii asju. Seda saab pikalt teha. Seda saab lühikeselt teha.
Õpetaja: Ee Siinkohal ma kasvan. Kasutan nüüd ai abi. Mina ei taha seda Seda asja. Et käi tsükliga läbi. Ee, leia niiöelda selle ee update checkboxi Pealt
Õpetaja: siukene
Õpetaja: võti nagu Transaction Type Id. Ja siis muuda ära nagu bla blabla. Ma põhimõtteliselt teen niimoodi et ma ütlen Aile, et ta aitaks selle ka ära teha. Ma panen lihtsalt kommenteerin kommentaarin. Selle Kommentaarin oled See vend, onju Ee? Ma ütlen nagu,
Õpetaja: ee. Käi Läbi jäi läbi. Jah, käi Juhtume korra Muretsen läbi korra. Ma kirjutan koodi.
Õpetaja: This punkt location punkt transaction types Ja ma saan nüüd selle teksti. Lihtsalt Käi läbi,
Õpetaja: ah? Võtame, niimoodi, et käi läbi. Disk. Blabla, bla, bla, laps.
Õpetaja: Jah, otsi ülesse Objekt,
Õpetaja: punkt.
Õpetaja: Update checkbox abil.
Õpetaja: Õige?
Õpetaja: Otsi ülesse Okei, selle Mõtleme objekti korra siit maha. Otsi ülesse. Update Checkbox punkt, transaction, Õige objekt,
Õpetaja: objekt ja muuda ära tema transaction type.
Õpetaja: Mis on Tema tema iss teema is available väärtus.
Õpetaja: Selliseks nagu on
Õpetaja: Update Checkbox punkt Shekted väärtus saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Noh, see asi nagu põhimõtteliselt oleks vaja ära teha.
Õpetaja: Mis me ikka Chatiga teeme? Teeme Cloud I lahti, siis ja suhtleme korra Cloudiga
Õpetaja: ära ja te võtate. Me võime korra Siis nagu selle koodi üle vaadata ja läbi rääkida, et kuidas ta nagu suures pildis töötab. Ma tean, et lihtsalt Ee on ka niuksed Suht Fancy D asjad millega, on võimalik väga lühikeselt ja elegantselt see kood teha. Me ei hakka ise tegema tsüklit võrdlema. If Ide asjadega
Õpetaja: ei vääri küünlaid.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ma ütlen talle. Vaatan, kas kontroller ka töötab või ei tööta.
Õpetaja: Control Iilt ka näed? Viitab sellele failile ja nendele ridadele,
Õpetaja: siis ütlen. Ee, ütleme, Cloud. Ile. Ole hea mees.
Õpetaja: Aita välja, välja.
Õpetaja: Naine.
Õpetaja: No vaata, mis ta ütleb. Maine, kui sa oled Naine, küsimärk.
Õpetaja: Aita välja hädast ja ta näeb seda. Näeb seda kommentaari. Ta saab aru, ta vaatab selle lahenduse ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaata, mis faile Ta siin loeb.
Õpetaja: Ta ühendas ära. Esiteks, selle, mis selle ka näete, pani ülesse
Õpetaja: Event Transaction types. Näete, kustutas ära. Punane See on, nagu näeks. Seal näeks neid muudatusi. Kustutas ära selle rea. Event Transaction Types update, et käivitab tühjust, Asendas selle niimoodi. Update Location Transaction meetodi ühtlasi Ta kirjutas selle meetodi. No vaata, mis ta tegi.
Õpetaja: Ta otsib kõigepealt Transaction Type I Ülesse sealt sellest Ee virrvarrist,
Õpetaja: ja siis ütleb, et Kui Transaction Type leidis.
Õpetaja: Väärtus, tuleb ülesse kirjutada sellega.
Õpetaja: Nojah, ma ei tea. Ee
Õpetaja: jah. Nojah, no jah. Näete, Siin on lambda funktsioon. Noh, ei oleks seda ühes ühesõnaga on Niukene meetod nagu Fine
Õpetaja: ja tema seest saab seda sama noolfunktsiooni kirjutada ja peale seda saad midagi võrrelda Ja sa saad teha nagu see ei vääri küünlaid,
Õpetaja: et nagu mis ta teeb. Nagu. Kuidas täpselt? Ma võin korra küsida, kas Ta pakuks ka mingit alternatiivset lahendust. Aga ma ma juba vist enamvähem Aiman. Et see, enamvähem nii Ongi
Õpetaja: Ee nagu üks parimaid, et mis ta teeb, Ta otsib ülesse
Õpetaja: target objekti
Õpetaja: varra eest.
Õpetaja: Kui seeni ei ole, on all.
Õpetaja: Kui objekt ei ole all siis järelikult midagi leidis, onju?
Õpetaja: Objekt on olemas.
Õpetaja: Noh, sulgudes ei ole nad.
Õpetaja: Siis muuda selle objekti ees available selleks.
Õpetaja: Nii nagu
Õpetaja: on selge.
Õpetaja: Ta käis läbi. Näete, siin ütleb Dislocation Find Ee location Transaction types. Find
Õpetaja: loob ühe uue sildikese, et igal igal tsüklil võtab. Ühe objekti. Transaction typesis ta Seob selle muutujaga, Me oleme teinud seda ju. Noh, seal Wen Blockis. Ja nii on ju
Õpetaja: tegevus.
Õpetaja: Find Il on kaks parameetrit. Näed, siin kuskil peaks olema, Ma täpselt ei tea, aga siia tuleb see objekt igal juhul.
Õpetaja: Ee, davaika. Ee lõppeks kindlasti lappesse. Selles mõttes et see on keeruline, vaata Aga see peab taustal niimoodi toimuma. Nagu selles mõttes, et me ei saa. Me ei saa muud moodi. Me peame ülevalt poolt andmeid sudima,
Õpetaja: Ee, et selles mõttes see lähenemine on. Igal juhul sama võib alati loomulikult küsida. Vaata, Cloud Code ilt ka, et kas sa teeksid kuidagi teistmoodi selle ära. Aga ma ütlen ka, et ta võib igasuguseid kontseptsioone ja asju siia niiöelda tuua ja lähenemisi, mida me lihtsalt ei õpeta Mida veel pole aega vaadata, onju? Ee, et ta teeb selle ära.
Õpetaja: See on kõige tähtsam.
Õpetaja: Järgmine kord kui nüüd jätkame homme, siis me Saame. Põhimõtteliselt. Meil vist on kõik olemas.
Õpetaja: Nagu Selles mõttes, et meil peaks. Noh, saab kiirelt kontrollida. Ka Töötab see asi ka üldse või Mitte onju? Olin Tallinn. Aa, sada. Ee. Kuuskümmend ee. Koma. Viiskümmend. Ee, raha välja.
Õpetaja: Nii, vaatan taustal meie Location objekti
Õpetaja: kõik asjad on muutunud. No, me oleme varem juba ära, aga lihtsalt. See on nüüd küsimus. Esimene asi on False Viimane asi on False Keskmine on true töötab,
Õpetaja: et me saime nagu selles mõttes toimiva lahenduse.
Õpetaja: Kuidas tänane päev tundus,
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd see viimane asi välja jätta. See mõttetus, see on savi, Lihtsalt kui me tegime neid lihtsaid asju, Nagu et
Õpetaja: kasutame Drop Down. I Ta saadab ülesse infot. Me täidame seal Location objektis ära. Me Tegime input kasti. Vaata, kus seal oli. Vaata, kui toimub mistahes muudatus. Saada ülesse, Saada kaks korrust. Ma mõtlen seda osa. Kas see osa Nagu enamvähem, nagu ei pea kõike Syntaxid peast teadma. Aga Mõttes saite aru,
Õpetaja: kuidas andmed peavad liikuma alla voolavad ülesse tulevad Teatega.
Õpetaja: Nii rohkem Selleks vist korraks polegi midagi. Aa, tulge oma ikka tagasi. Asjad lähevad ainult. Aa, hullemaks.
Õpetaja: Alg paremaks.
Õpetaja: Ee, kas ma ütlen välja, mida ma mõtlesin, Ei, ole, ee, mis mul on. Nagu mõttes on nüüd see, et me teeme selle saatmise ära,
Õpetaja: saadame ära ja mul tegelikult on Mõte, et tõmbame võibolla Frontiga joone alla. Korra siin, vahetunnis. Teistega. Rääkisin ka,
Õpetaja: et me hakkame nüüd ee vaatama asju ja me jätame endale Piisavalt asju, mida toimetada, et kui meidi aega teeme, et me tuleme tagasi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi, et me õpime selle asja kuni lõpuni ära, Siis tal on midagi Nagu meeles midagi saate aru. Siis hakkame Packi hüppama. Packi asjad kuidagi muutuvad lõpuks selgeks ja Frondi asjad on meelest ära läinud, et siis lõpus on meil natukene veel teha. Update ja delik.
Õpetaja: Midagi taolist. Ja modal ka front I asja, aga siis on Väike vaheldus ka.
Õpetaja: Aa, et seda asja on juba veits tehtud. Ja väga chill. Aga nagu meil on vaja ka tegelikult lihtsalt ka sellepärast Meil on vaja hakata õppima neid Ee, back I kontseptsioone. Lihtsalt need ka. Kuidagi. Kõik veel praegult, nagu on seoses.
Õpetaja: Aga te ikkagi praegult, Nagu jagate need fondi asju. Päkkis Tegelikult suurt, mitte ööd ega mütsi,
Õpetaja: et ee päkist veel on vaja õppida, et umbes niukse plaaniga Sõidame. Homme teeme veel midagi ja võibolla juba homme juba teeme Packi. Oleneb, kuidas me jõuame.
Õpetaja: Page on vaim valmis. Kuulge, aitäh. Ee, Adieu
Õpetaja: Ka See veb üksteist. Tegelikult ta kind on done, aga ei ole. Sõnumuti ei ole saatnud, onju?
Õpetaja: Sõnumit ei ole saatnud.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah, Davai Tsauka.